Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. The key at Antwerp, a steamer moored alongside, the musical chimes winging from the old cathedral spire, the sound of the brabant son, the Belgian national anthem. On the key and on the steamer's decks, a jostling motley crowd. Military uniforms, the flutter of women's dresses, ships' officers gliding to and fro, the hatches battening down, steam getting up. Surrounded by groups of relatives or boon companions, passengers bound Congo woods, men of whose fitness for residing and governing
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。安特卫普的码头上，一艘蒸汽船停泊在岸边，悠扬的钟声从老天主教堂的尖顶上飘荡开来，布拉班特之声（Brabant Son）的旋律响起——那是比利时的国歌。码头上和汽船的甲板上，挤满了熙熙攘熙、形形色色的人群。军服闪烁，女人们的裙裾飘扬，船上军官们来回穿梭，货舱正紧锣密鼓地加盖舱盖，蒸汽机蓄势待发。在亲朋好友或酒肉朋友的簇拥下，那些开往刚果森林的旅客们——其中许多人连初学者都会怀疑他们是否适合在
in tropical Africa even a novice would have doubts, young mostly and mostly of a poor type, undersized pallid wastrels. But here and there, an older bronzed individual, Here and there, an older bronzed individual, one who has obviously been through all this before. The faces of these distinctly not good to look upon. Scarred with brutality, with cruel and lustful eyes. Faces from which one turns with an involuntary shudder of repulsion. So that is the scene at Antwerp, it's a great port in Belgium from where the steamships head west and south to the Congo Free State in the late 1890s as described by a barrel-chested
热带非洲居住和统治——大多是年轻人，且大多年景不佳、身材矮小、面色苍白、游手好闲。但偶尔也能看到一个饱经风霜、皮肤晒成古铜色的中年人，偶尔也能看到一个饱经风霜、皮肤晒成古铜色的中年人，这种人显然以前已经经历过这一切。这些人的面孔绝对算不上好看。带着残暴的伤疤，眼神残酷而好色。那些让人看一眼就会不由自主地感到一阵抗拒和战栗的面孔。这就是18世纪90年代末安特卫普的景象——那是比利时的一个伟大港口，蒸汽船从这里向西、向南开往刚果自由邦——正如一位胸膛宽阔、
handlebar moustachioed young man called Edmund Dean Morell. And Dominic I hope that you admire the way in which I evoked the sense of a barrel chested handlebar, moustached young man there. Well, the one thing that was missing, so two things that were missing, Morel was born in France and his father was French and then he went to boarding school in England. So you should have done an accent that was across the street. Oh, like Theo Young Smith. Right, like Theo Young Smith. That's the voice you should have done.
留着上翘式八字胡的年轻男子埃德蒙·迪恩·莫雷尔（Edmund Dean Morell）所描述的那样。多米尼克，我希望你赞赏我刚才唤起的那种胸膛宽阔、留着八字胡的年轻男子的意境。好吧，其中缺少的有一点，或者说两点：莫雷尔出生于法国，他的父亲是法国人，后来他在英国的一所寄宿学校上学。所以你本该模仿一种跨国（越洋）口音。哦，就像西奥·杨·史密斯（Theo Young Smith）。没错，就像西奥·杨·史密斯。那才是你本该模仿的声音。
Theo has many qualities, but he's not barrel chested. He's not barrel chested. He's not barrel chested. So yes, I think you, you captured the barrel chest very nicely there, Tom. Thank you. Thank you, Dominic. The reason we're talking about this guy, Edmund D. Morell is that basically he is the hero of today's episode, isn't he?
西奥有很多优点，但他不是宽胸膛。他不是宽胸膛。他不是宽胸膛。所以，是的，我觉得你，你刚才把那个宽胸膛的形象抓得很准，汤姆。谢谢你。谢谢你，多米尼克。我们之所以要谈论这个叫埃德蒙·D·莫雷尔（Edmund D. Morell）的家伙，是因为他基本上就是今天这集节目的英雄，不是吗？
He is the man who draws the crimes of King Leopold's Congo Free State to the world's attention and is probably the most effective human rights campaigner of the 20th century. He establishes the template for all the human rights campaigns that have followed. Yeah, he absolutely is. He is the link between the abolitionist movement, the fought slavery in Britain, America and elsewhere, a generation before, and the human rights campaigns of the later 20th century, the anti-apartheid campaign, and so on and so forth.
他就是把利奥波德国王的刚果自由邦的罪行公之于世的人，也可能是20世纪最有效的人权活动家。他为后来所有的人权运动树立了样板。是的，他绝对是。他是连接前一代在英国、美国及其他地方反对奴隶制的废奴运动，与20世纪后期的人权运动（如反种族隔离运动等等）之间的纽带。
And today's episode really is the story of how he and his friends and his allies bring down Leopold's regime. Last week, we heard about how since 1885 King Leopold, the second of Belgium, has presided over this reign of terror in the Congo Free State in pursuit of ivory and rubber and of course money. And this is the story of how he loses his grip. The Congo doesn't become independent or free, of course, it passes into Belgian government hands, but Leopold loses this prize that he has spent all his life, um, trying to, to seize and then trying to sort of hide from the world's gaze.
而今天的节目实际上讲述的就是他、他的朋友和盟友们如何推翻利奥波德政权的故事。上周，我们听闻了自1885年以来，比利时国王利奥波德二世为了追逐象牙、橡胶，当然还有金钱，一直在刚果自由邦实行这种恐怖统治。而这个故事讲述的是他是如何失去对局势的掌控的。当然，刚果并没有因此变得独立或自由，它落入了比利时政府的手中，但利奥波德失去了他毕生都在试图攫取、然后又试图向世界隐瞒的这个战利品。
So yeah, this is Edmund de Morel story really. So let's talk a little bit about him, Tom. He is born in Paris in 1873, uh, father, French French mother and English Quaker, which may be relevant. His father died when he was young. He went to boarding school in England. He ended up becoming a British subject and becoming a clerk. And he's an obscure man. When he's 18 years old, he starts work for a Liverpool shipping company called Elder
所以，是的，这确实是埃德蒙·德·莫雷尔（Edmund de Morel）的故事。那么我们来稍微谈谈他吧，汤姆。他于1873年出生在巴黎，呃，父亲是法国人，母亲是法国人，还有一个英国贵格会教徒母亲，这可能是相关的。他父亲在他很小的时候就去世了。他在英国的一所寄宿学校上学。他最终加入了英国国籍，并成为了一名职员。他曾是一个无名小卒。在他18岁的时候，他开始为一家名为埃尔德·邓普斯特（Elder
Dempster. And as luck would have it, this shipping company has the contract for the steam ship trade to the Congo. They have a monopoly. So they handle all the steam ships that go to and from the Congo. And that is very much dependent on the company retaining the favour of Leopold II, isn't it? Exactly. They have been given the contract by the Congo Free State and obviously they don't want to lose it. It brings them in a lot of money. Now by the late 1890s, at which point Morel is in his mid-twenties, they are sending him often every month to Antwerp because of course he speaks French.
Dempster）的利物浦航运公司工作。真走运，这家公司拥有前往刚果的轮船贸易合同。他们拥有垄断权。因此，他们处理所有往返刚果的轮船。而这很大程度上取决于该公司能否继续保持利奥波德二世的青睐，对吧？一点没错。他们获得了刚果自由邦授予的合同，显然他们不想失去这个合同。这为他们带来了巨额资金。到了19世纪90年代末，当时的莫雷尔正值二十五六岁，公司经常每个月派他去安特卫普，因为他当然会说法语。
So, you know, he's a useful employee. He's the ideal person basically to stand there at the quayside, supervising the arrivals and departures of all these steamships. He's already interested in Africa. Why wouldn't he be? You know, Africa is a very exotic and exciting subject in the 1890s. He thinks the Congo free state is brilliant. He believes what he reads in the newspapers about its civilizing mission. He actually writes articles about Africa and about the Congo Free State for industry magazines
所以，你知道，他是一个有用的员工。他基本上是站在码头上监督所有这些轮船抵港和离港的理想人选。他对非洲已经很感兴趣。为什么不呢？你知道，在19世纪90年代，非洲是一个非常异国情调且令人兴奋的主题。他认为刚果自由邦棒极了。他相信自己在报纸上读到的关于其文明使命的报道。他实际上还为行业杂志撰写过关于非洲和刚果自由邦的文章，
because he fancies himself as a bit of a writer. And he says, it's got a great future, King Leopold, a tremendous fellow, all of this kind of thing. But also, I suppose, because he's investing his future in the company. Yeah, of course. Why wouldn't you want to read up about business that you're involved in? Absolutely, absolutely. But he's standing there on the quayside at Antwerp and he's watching that scene
因为他自认为有点写作才华。他说，刚果自由邦有着伟大的未来，利奥波德国王是个了不起的家伙，诸如此类。但我想，这也是因为他把自己的未来投资在了这家公司上。对，当然。你为什么不想了解你所参与的业务呢？完全正确，完全正确。但他站在安特卫普的码头上，看着那个
that we described earlier and he starts to become suspicious of the ships that he sees because as we described at the end of last week's episode, he sees all this rubber and ivory being unloaded from the ships, but nothing is going back the other way. So he kind of thinks, well, what are we trading for? What are we giving them in return? Now, at one point, he's called in by the Secretary of State of the Congo, who's this, he describes as a man thin to emaciation, inhuman, bloodless, petrified. I mean, there is a quality of Bram Stoker to quite a lot of what he's writing about sinister things in crates.
我们之前描述过的场景，他开始对自己看到的船只产生怀疑，因为正如我们在上集节目末尾所描述的那样，他看到大量橡胶和象牙从船上卸下，却没有东西运回。所以他不禁心想，好吧，我们在交换什么？我们到底回馈了他们什么？此时，他被刚果国务秘书召见，他形容这个人“瘦骨嶙峋，非人，毫无血色，犹如石化”。我的意思是，他在描写板条箱里那些阴暗事物时，行文风格中确实带有一种布拉姆·斯托克（Bram Stoker）的味道。
Exactly. I was about to say there was something of the Hollywood melodrama, but actually the comparison with Dracula is a really nice one. This man calls him in and he's absolutely furious. He says the newspapers have reported what was in one of our recent shipments back to the Congo, a huge consignment of guns. And this sort of stuff shouldn't be appearing in the newspapers, make sure it doesn't happen again.
完全正确。我正要说这有点像好莱坞情节剧，但实际上，与《德古拉》的对比确实非常贴切。这个人把他叫去，并勃然大怒。他说报纸报道了我们最近运回刚果的一批货物中的内容——那是一大批枪支。这种东西不应该出现在报纸上，确保以后不要再发生了。
And Morell is confused by this. He thinks, well, why are we shipping so many guns back to the Congo? Why, and why can't the newspapers report it? Why is it, why is it such a big deal? I mean, it's interesting that the guy assumes that Morell would understand. Yes, exactly. There isn't that so interesting. Well, I think a lot of people perhaps would not have been curious. Morel has a he's curious. So he goes away and he
莫雷尔对此感到困惑。他心想，好吧，我们为什么要向刚果运送这么多枪支？为什么，为什么报纸不能报道？为什么这，为什么这是一件大事？我的意思是，有趣的是，这家伙竟然以为莫雷尔会懂。是的，完全如此。难道这不是很奇怪吗？好吧，我想很多人可能不会去好奇。而莫雷尔有一个——他很好奇。所以他走开了，开始
starts just idly almost looking into the account books looking into the figures in the office. And he thinks this is weird, nothing really adds up. The accounts that he sees, the figures written down, the ledgers, don't match what he can see coming off the ships, the massive consignments of rubber and ivory. And that's not reflected in the earnings. And it becomes obvious to him that there's a lot of fraud going on. Somebody is skimming off the top. And the answer, of course course is King Leopold. King Leopold is lying about the amount coming in and about how much money he's making. But the other thing that becomes obvious to him once he starts going through all
近乎随性地开始查阅办公室里的账本、查阅数据。他觉得这很诡异，一切根本对不上号。他看到的账目、写下来的数字以及总账，与他亲眼所见从船上卸下的海量橡胶和象牙根本不匹配。这并没有反映在收益中。他渐渐明白，这里面存在着大量的欺诈。有人在从中捞取油水。而答案，当然就是利奥波德国王。利奥波德国王在收入金额以及他赚了多少钱这方面一直在撒谎。但一旦他开始翻阅所有
these kind of dusty ledgers is that consignment of guns was not the exception. It was the rule. They are sending thousands and thousands of guns and rounds of ammunition to the Congo and nothing else. And we entered last week's episode with his great moment of revelation, a very kind of Hollywood scene. I was giddy and appalled at the cumulative significance of my discoveries. It must be bad enough to stumble upon a murder.
这些积满灰尘的总账，变得显而易见的另一件事是，那批枪支并不是特例。这是常态。他们向刚果运送了成千上万支枪支和数不清的弹药，除此之外什么都没有。我们在上集节目的结尾迎来了他的重大启示时刻，那是一个非常具有好莱坞风格的场景：“我的发现在累积起来的意义面前让我感到头晕目眩、惊骇不已。偶然撞见谋杀案已经够糟糕的了。
I had stumbled upon a secret society of murderers with a king for a ringleader. I mean, it would make a great film wouldn't it? It would absolutely. Tabby our assistant producer said it reminded her of the Robert Harris novel about the Dreyfus case, an officer and a spy and it very much has that quality. Yeah, yeah kind of whistleblower. Exactly. So Morrell goes to see the head of the company, whose man called Sir Alfred Jones, the head of the shipping magnate. So he must be thrilled.
而我撞见的是一个由国王充当头目的谋杀犯秘密社团。”我的意思是，这会是一部很棒的电影，对吧？绝对是的。塔比（Tabby），我们的助理制作人说，这让她想起罗伯特·哈里斯（Robert Harris）关于德雷福斯事件的小说《军官与间谍》（An Officer and a Spy），而且确实非常具有这种特质。对，对，有点像吹哨人。完全正确。于是莫雷尔去见了公司的负责人，这个人叫阿尔弗雷德·琼斯爵士（Sir Alfred Jones），这位航运巨头的掌门人。所以他一定欣喜若狂吧。
Of course, Sir Alfred Jones is horrified when Morel says, I found all these discrepancies and I'm extremely concerned. Jones says, well, listen, I'll go to Brussels myself and I'll talk to the king about it. Then Jones calls in Morel a few weeks later and says, well, I've been to Brussels. I saw the king. The king said, yes, he's very disturbed about what you've discovered. He'll set up a commission. Exactly. Reforms will be carried out.
当然，当莫雷尔说“我发现了所有这些出入，我感到极其担忧”时，阿尔弗雷德·琼斯爵士吓坏了。琼斯说：“好吧，听着，我自己去一趟布鲁塞尔，我会跟国王谈谈这件事的。”随后，琼斯在几周后把莫雷尔叫去并说道：“嗯，我去过布鲁塞尔了。我见到了国王。国王说，是的，他对你发现的情况感到非常不安。他将成立一个委员会。”完全正确。“将实施改革。”
He said, and Sir Alfred says to Morel, you know, don't worry. The Belgians are doing great things and we have to give them time to get their African house in order. In the next few months, Morel finds that he's being frozen out. He's not going to Antwerp as much as he was. Then he's offered a promotion. Great news. You've done so well and you're going to be posted overseas. And then he says, no, I don't want to go overseas. I want to stay in Britain. And then he is offered another promotion to become a consultant pushed up
他说，阿尔弗雷德爵士对莫雷尔说：“你知道的，别担心。比利时人在做伟大的事情，我们必须给他们时间来整顿他们在非洲的烂摊子。”在接下来的几个月里，莫雷尔发现自己被排挤在外。他去安特卫普的次数不如以前那么频繁了。接着他得到了一次晋升。好消息！你干得太棒了，你将被派往海外任职。然后他说：“不，我不想去海外。我想留在英国。”接着他又得到了另一次晋升，担任顾问，被推向
the ladder of the company. And it's very clear to him that the company are now trying to shut him up. Or to offer him a bribe. Effective or both. I mean, that's both that that's what they're trying to do. They're trying to either get him out of the picture or push him upstairs, push him into a back office. Well paid, stay quiet. So in 1901, at the age of 28, he resigns from Elder Dempster and he resigns to become a full-time writer, but not just any writer. As he wrote himself, his goal was, and I quote, to do my best to expose and destroy what I then knew to be a legalized infamy, accompanied by unimaginable barbarities and responsible for a vast destruction of human life.
公司的更高阶梯。他十分清楚，公司现在正试图让他闭嘴。或者说给他行贿。有效，或者两者皆有。我的意思是，这既是——这正是他们试图做的事。他们要么试图让他从视线中消失，要么把他往高处推，把他推到一个后台办公室。给高薪，让他闭嘴。于是，在1901年，28岁的他从埃尔德·邓普斯特公司辞职了；他辞职是为了成为一名全职作家，但绝非泛泛之作。正如他自己所写的那样，他的目标是——我引用他的话——“尽我所能揭露并摧毁我当时所知的这种将非法人性合法化的行为，伴随着难以想象的野蛮行径，并造成了大量人类生命的毁灭。”
In other words, he has quit the company to become a full-time campaigner, to become an activist effectively. Now the real puzzle is why? What is it in him that makes him want to do this? See, I don't think it's a puzzle at all. I know what you're going to say. Well, and I think Hochschild actually agrees because he wrote a kind of second edition about this. So I think it's the influence of his mother, who's a Quaker. And throughout this podcast, we've talked about the role played by Quakers
换句话说，他辞去了公司的职务，成为了一名全职的活动家，实际上变成了一名维权人士。现在真正的谜团是：为什么？他内心是什么促使他想要这样做的？你看，我一点也不觉得这是一个谜。我知道你要说什么。好吧，而且我认为霍克希尔（Hochschild）实际上也同意这一点，因为他为此写了某种第二版。所以我觉得这是他母亲的影响，她是一位贵格会教徒。在这整个播客中，我们一直在讨论贵格会教徒在人权运动中所起的作用，
in human rights campaigns, um, abolition of slavery being the obvious example. And although it is true as Hoxhjalt says that, um, Morrell is not conventionally religious, he, he's not, he doesn't attend Quaker meetings or Church of England services or anything like that. Nevertheless, it's clear that he has absorbed values, I would say, from his parents, probably particularly from his mother, and that this is manifesting itself through his moral assumptions and his campaigning zeal. Well, that is one possible explanation. The only downside with that is there's absolutely no evidence for it because we do know that
废除奴隶制就是最明显的例子。虽然正如霍克希尔所说，莫雷尔并不是传统意义上的宗教信徒，他不是，他不去参加贵格会聚会或英国国教礼拜或诸如此类的活动。尽管如此，很显然，他吸收了各种价值观——我要说——来自他的父母，可能特别是来自他的母亲，而这正通过他的道德假设和他的维权热情体现出来。好吧，那是一种可能的解释。唯一的不利之处在于，完全没有任何证据支持这一点，因为我们确实知道
he's in no way personally religious and there's no evidence that his mother did have this influence on him. So it's a supposition and it's not an unreasonable one, but it's only a supposition. He has values. Yes, he does. Where do these values come from? I mean, they don't just magically materialize. Maybe they come from his boarding school, Tom.
他在个人信仰上绝对不是宗教人士，也没有证据表明他母亲对他有过这种影响。所以这只是一种推测，而且并非不合理，但它仅仅是一种推测。他有价值观。是的，他确实有。这些价值观从何而来？我的意思是，它们不会凭空出现。也许它们来自他的寄宿学校，汤姆。
You're underplaying the importance of a school, which is sad. Well, maybe. I mean, you have a sense of campaigning zeal of a particular commitment to notions of human rights, a long historical tradition. His mother belongs to that tradition. He manifests that tradition. I would say it's the likeliest explanation. Well, the truth of the matter, of course, is we don't know what we
你低估了学校的重要性，这很悲哀。好吧，也许吧。我的意思是，你有一种维权的热情，对人权观念有着特殊的承诺，这是一项悠久的历史传统。他的母亲属于那个传统。他体现了那个传统。我认为这是最可能的解释。好吧，事实的真相当然是，我们并不知道。我们
do know is he does feel personally responsible, because he has worked for the company. And I think that's a huge part of this story. And it is also with his great ally who we'll come to later. This is the story of two men who both felt implicated because they had both been perhaps naive in some way. Well, but think of Benjamin Lay going to the Caribbean and feeling personally implicated in slavery there. I think the parallels are very, very clear.
所知道的是，他确实感到了个人的责任感，因为他曾为这家公司工作过。我认为这是这个故事中非常重要的一部分。这也是关于他与他的一位伟大盟友的故事，我们稍后会讲到。这是一个关于两个男人的故事，他们都感到自己牵涉其中，因为他们两人此前在某种程度上都可能过于天真了。好吧，但想想本杰明·莱（Benjamin Lay）去加勒比海并感到自己与那里的奴隶制有个人牵连。我认为两者的平行关系非常非常清晰。
It's a very common story, actually. Some of the keenest abolitionists tend to be people who've been involved with the trade in some way. Anyway, at first, he struggles. And this is something actually that Adam Hochschild's book doesn't really capture, that actually at first he succeeds only because he gets funding from a rival Liverpool shipping tycoon. And this is a guy called John Holt, who's a rival of Sir Alfred Jones and gives him the money to found his own paper, the West African Mail. So there's a really good article on this by a scholar called Dean Clay.
这其实是一个很普遍的故事。一些最热心的废奴主义者往往是那些曾以某种方式参与过奴隶贸易的人。无论如何，起初，他举步维艰。而这一点其实是亚当·霍克希尔（Adam Hochschild）的书里并没有真正捕捉到的：事实上，他起初之所以成功，仅仅是因为他得到了利物浦一家竞争对手航运大亨的资金支持。这个人叫约翰·霍尔特（John Holt），他是阿尔弗雷德·琼斯爵士的竞争对手，他给了莫雷尔资金去创办他自己的报纸——《西非邮报》（West African Mail）。所以，一位名叫迪恩·克莱（Dean Clay）的学者对此有一篇非常精彩的文章。
And he points out that basically this is a question, not just of altruism, but of business rivalry. This rival tycoon wants to bring down Elder Dempster, or at least do them down a bit. So he gives Morell the money to do his campaign. And Morell starts to pour out not just, you know, dozens of articles, thousands of words, but millions of words. So an enormous quantity of what we have been saying in this podcast about the Congo comes from Edmund D. Morell because he is the single biggest source. He's publishing books, he's publishing articles, editorials. When you look behind so many of the anecdotes and the quotations and indeed the statistics, they come from this one man. And he never goes to the Congo, that's the thing, rather like King Leopold. But the extraordinary thing is he is absolutely brilliant at persuading insiders,
他指出，这基本上不仅是一个利他主义的问题，也是一个商业竞争的问题。这位竞争对手大亨想要打倒埃尔德·邓普斯特公司，或者至少想让他们吃点苦头。所以他给了莫雷尔资金来开展他的运动。于是莫雷尔开始倾泻的不仅是——你知道的——几十篇文章、几千字，而是数百万字。因此，我们在本播客中关于刚果所说的大量内容都来自于埃德蒙·D·莫雷尔，因为他是单一最大的来源。他在出版书籍、发表文章、社论。当你深入探究那么多的轶事、引言甚至是统计数据时，它们都来自这同一个人。而他从未去过刚果，这就是关键所在，就像利奥波德国王一样。但非凡之处在于，他极其擅长说服内部人士，
even people within the mercenary force, the force public, to leak material to him. Which goes back to your question, Tom, last week about, are there people who feel guilty? Are there people who feel, who have regrets or have doubts? They clearly are because from 1901, they are feeding this guy information, the facts and figures and anecdotes and all of these kinds of things. And I suppose the situation for them was that if they're feeling a sense of guilt about what they've been doing, they don't have a vent for it. But Morel's appearance on the scene provides them with just that vent.
甚至包括雇佣军部队（Force Publique）内部的人向他泄露材料。这回到了你上周提出的问题，汤姆：有没有人感到内疚？有没有人感到后悔或有疑虑？显然是有的，因为从1901年起，他们就在向这个人提供信息、事实、数据、轶事以及所有这类东西。我想对他们来说，当时的情况是，如果他们对自己的所作所为感到内疚，他们却没有一个宣泄的出口。但莫雷尔的出现恰好为他们提供了这样一个宣泄口。
Exactly. He gets so much information, he starts to taunt the administration of the Congo. He'll print lists of things that their own employees have offered to sell him. He'll say, basically, here's the bullet pointed list of the things that I'm being offered. At one point, they issue an instruction to their subordinates. They say, stop writing things down because Morell is reprinting them in his newspaper. He gets hold of that order and he prints that in his newspaper as well. So he's sort of he's mocking them the whole time. But his single most powerful source actually, this will please you, Tom. It doesn't please me, but it doesn't surprise me.
完全正确。他获得了如此之多的信息，以至于他开始嘲弄刚果当局。他会打印出他们的员工主动向他兜售的物品清单。他基本上会说，以下是我被兜售物品的要点列表。有一次，他们向下属发布了一条指示。他们说：“别再把事情写下来了，因为莫雷尔正在他的报纸上重新刊登这些内容。”他弄到了那道命令，并把它也印在了他的报纸上。所以他一直在某种程度上嘲弄他们。但他最强大的单一消息来源其实——这会让你高兴的，汤姆。这并不让我高兴，但这并不让我感到意外。
Let's put it like that. It's not from within the administration, but it's missionaries. So many of the most shocking stories that we mentioned last week about floggings, about beatings, about these horrendous atrocities, these are from Protestant missionaries, often British, American American or Scandinavian.
让我们这么说吧。消息来源不是来自行政部门内部，而是来自传教士。我们在上周提到的许多关于鞭笞、殴打以及这些骇人听闻的暴行的最令人震惊的故事，都来自于新教传教士，通常是英国、美国或斯堪的纳维亚传教士。
So we said in the previous episode about the hand chopping, the most notorious manifestation of barbarism in the Congo, that these were usually from corpses, from dead people. But there is one horrible account by an American missionary where he described seeing soldiers cut off someone's hand and quote while the poor heart beat strongly enough to shoot the blood from the cut arteries at a distance of fully four feet. I mean, once you read details like that, they kind of see it on the mind, aren't they? They are see it on the mind and that's partly why his campaign is so effective. So by about
所以我们在上一集中说过，关于砍手——刚果野蛮行径中最臭名昭著的表现——这些手通常来自尸体，来自死者。但有一个美国传教士留下的可怕记述，他描述自己看到士兵砍下某人的手，并且“引述：当可怜的心脏跳动得足够强劲时，竟将鲜血从被切断的动脉中喷射出足足四英尺远。”我的意思是，一旦你读到这样的细节，它们就会深深地印在脑海里，不是吗？它们确实深深地印在脑海里，这也是他的运动如此之成功的部分原因。所以大约到
1903, within two years of leaving his job, Morel has managed to, by writing and writing and writing, and he's got all these great journalistic contacts, he places pieces everywhere, he's managed to make this a political issue in Britain. And in May 1903, the House of Commons actually holds a debate on the Congo Free State. There is a motion to call upon the signatories to the Conference of Berlin to take measures to ensure that the Congolese people are going to be treated with greater humanity. And the motion is introduced
1903年，即他离职后的两年内，莫雷尔通过不断的写作，并借助他所有的伟大新闻界人脉，将文章投递到各处，成功地将此事在英国变成了一个政治议题。1903年5月，下议院实际上就刚果自由邦举行了一场辩论。有一项动议呼吁柏林会议的签字国采取措施，确保刚果人民得到更具人道主义的对待。该动议由
by the Liberal MP Herbert Samuel. And he in his speech, so I had to look at Hansard for the text of the debate, he deplores what he calls the seething turmoil and barbarous acts of repression under King Leopold. You know, he doesn't hold back. But the brilliant thing for us, Tom, is that he presents this as a great patriotic British endeavor to clean this up. It's always been the boast of this country, says Herbert Samuel, not only that our own native subjects are governed on principles of justice, but that ever since the days of Wilberforce, England has been the leader in all movements on behalf
自由党议员赫伯特·塞缪尔（Herbert Samuel）提出。他在发言中——所以我不得不查阅《汉萨德》（Hansard）来获取辩论文本——谴责了他所谓的利奥波德国王统治下“汹涌的动荡和野蛮的镇压行径”。你知道，他毫不掩饰。但对我们来说妙不可言的是，汤姆，他将此表现为一场伟大的、旨在清理这一切的英国爱国主义壮举。“这个国家一向引以为豪的，”赫伯特·塞缪尔说，“不仅在于我们自己的本土臣民是在正义原则下受到统治的，而且自威伯福斯（Wilberforce）时代以来，英国一直是所有代表地球上
of the backward races of the earth. Here is an occasion when those responsible for our policy might pursue these great traditions and add to the annals of the good deeds of this country. I mean, there is, of course, a lot going on there. There's a lot going on there. But just to point out that, of course, Britain's preponderance in the anti-slavery campaign and now as is being proposed in the campaign against the depredations in the Congo is dependent on her global power.
落后种族的运动的领袖。这是一个承担我们政策的人能够奉行这些伟大传统并为这个国家的善行史册增光添彩的契机。”我的意思是，这其中当然有很多门道。这其中有很多门道。但只需指出一点，当然，英国在反奴隶制运动中的主导地位，以及现在正如人们所提议的在反对刚果掠夺行为的运动中的主导地位，都取决于其全球力量。
Yes, of course. Dependent on the Navy and dependent by implication on the possession of her empire. And so essentially what is being offered is a kind of form of liberal imperialism. Absolutely. The British Empire exists as a force for good. And I mean, this is, this is something that has been manifest in the campaign against slavery right from the time of Napoleon. So the Congress of Vienna, it is mass demonstrations in Britain that forces Lord Castlereagh, the foreign secretary, to go to the Congress of Vienna and say,
是的，当然。取决于海军，并暗中取决于其帝国的拥有。因此，本质上所提供的是一种自由主义帝国的形式。绝对的。大英帝国作为一个正义的力量存在。我的意思是，从拿破仑时代起，这在反对奴隶制的运动中就一直显而易见。因此，在维也纳会议上，正是英国国内的大规模游说迫使外交大臣卡苏利雷勋爵（Lord Castlereagh）前往维也纳会议并说：
guys, I'm really sorry. We've got to write in all this antislavery stuff. And kind of the same thing is happening now because the motion is carried in the Commons and it is proposed that all the countries that had been participants in the commons and it is proposed that all the countries that had been participants in the Berlin conference should get together and press for a Congo state that is governed with humanity.
“各位，真的很抱歉。我们必须把所有这些反奴隶制的内容写进去。”现在也发生了类似的事情，因为该动议在下议院获得通过，并提议所有曾参与柏林会议的国家都应该聚在一起，施压要求建立一个以人道方式统治的刚果国。
Exactly. Exactly. So it's supreme irony is that it's Britain's imperial position that allows it to take this view, which of course some listeners may say is rank hypocrisy, but others may say is an example of the kind of ambiguity of Empire, right? Well, we'll be talking about this, won't we, in our bonus episode? Exactly. Now, the Foreign Office, when it hears about this debate, says, okay, you know, let's not rush into anything. Let's actually try to get some hard evidence ourselves rather
完全正确。完全正确。因此，最大的讽刺在于，正是英国的帝国地位使其能够持这种立场，当然，有些听众可能会说这是虚伪至极，但其他人可能会说这是帝国模棱两可性的一种体现，对吧？好吧，我们会在我们的加权（加更）节目中谈到这一点，对吧？没错。现在，外交部听到这场辩论后说：“好吧，你知道的，不要急于下结论。让我们自己去寻找一些确凿的证据，
than relying on us activists. We have a man on the ground in the Congo and we'll ask him to find out exactly what's going on. And now we come to the other great hero of this story. And this is a man called Roger Casement. And next week, Tom, I know you're going to be talking to the Irish novelist, the great prize winning novelist, John Banville, about Roger Casement's story. He's an extraordinarily interesting figure. There's a richly fascinating life.
而不是依赖于我们这些维权人士。我们在刚果有驻地人员，我们会请他去查明究竟发生了什么。”现在我们来到了这个故事的另一位伟大英雄。这个人就是罗杰·卡斯门特（Roger Casement）。下周，汤姆，我知道你要和爱尔兰小说家、伟大的获奖小说家约翰·班维尔（John Banville）谈论罗杰·卡斯门特的故事。他是一个极其有趣的人物。有着极其迷人的一生。
So John Banville will be talking about him because in John Banville's opinion, Roger Casement is the greatest of Irishmen. High praise. Because we should mention he's the British Consul, but he is Irish. Yes. So just very quickly on Casement, because we'll be doing him next week. Casement is born to a Protestant family in Dublin. He went to the Congo when he was 19 years old.
所以约翰·班维尔将会谈论他，因为在约翰·班维尔看来，罗杰·卡斯门特是爱尔兰人中最伟大的。高度的赞誉。因为我们应该提到，他是英国领事，但他却是爱尔兰人。是的。所以我们简短地提一下卡斯门特，因为我们下周会详细讲他。卡斯门特出生于都柏林的一个新教家庭。他19岁时去了刚果。
He is implicated. He had worked for Henry Morton Stanley as a surveyor. He'd worked on the route for Leopold's railway. Casement is a very handsome, striking man, an enormous black beard, great sense of natural dignity, very polite. He's a great talker. Everybody comments about his voice,
他与此有牵连。他曾为亨利·莫顿·斯坦利（Henry Morton Stanley）担任过测量员。他曾在利奥波德的铁路路线上工作过。卡斯门特是一个非常英俊、引人注目的人，有着浓密的黑胡子，极具自然尊严，非常礼貌。他很会聊天。每个人都对他的声音评头论足，
says what a beautiful voice he has. No sense of humor whatsoever, I think it is fair to say, which is always a good thing in an activist, by the way. You don't want them to be sort of ironic. You want them to be earnest. And everybody always remarks how kind and gentle he is. Even when he first arrived in the Congo, people said he's kind of, he's very nice to the, to the Africans.
说他的声音有多么动听。毫不幽默感，我觉得可以这么说，顺便说一句，这在维权人士身上总是一件好事。你可不希望他们带有什么讽刺意味。你希望他们是极其认真的。每个人都总是称赞他是多么的善良和温和。甚至当他刚到达刚果时，人们就说他某种程度上——他对非洲人非常好。
People said he was too nice. He gives away too much. Joseph Conrad had met him in his journey in 1890. Well, they'd gone together on the, the Rwanda Belge, the steamship. They had hung out together. Conrad had written in his journal that Casement was most intelligent and very sympathetic. And Casement undoubtedly had heard stories about the darkness because we know that in 1887 he'd been on the steamboat with a Belgian officer who said, ah, life
人们说他太好了。他给予得太多了。约瑟夫·康拉德（Joseph Conrad）在1890年的旅程中曾与他相遇。好吧，他们曾一起乘坐“卢旺达·比利时号”（Rwanda Belge）蒸汽船。他们曾一起混在一起。康拉德在日记中写道，卡斯门特非常聪明，也非常富有同情心。卡斯门特无疑听说过关于黑暗的故事，因为我们知道，在1887年，他曾与一名比利时军官同乘一艘汽船，那名军官说：“啊，刚果的生活
in the Congo is brilliant. I pay my men five brass rods for every severed head they bring me. Well, I think the assumption is, isn't it, on the darkening sense Conrad has of imperialism derives a lot from Casement. So Casement had joined the British Colonial Service, he'd worked elsewhere in Africa. And then in 1901, the Foreign Office sent him back to the Congo as Britain's consul. And before going to the Congo, he went to see King Leopold in Brussels. King Leopold said, oh, brilliant. I hope you have a great time to the Congo, he went to see King Leopold in Brussels. King Leopold said, oh, brilliant. I hope you have a great time in the Congo.
太棒了。他们每带回一颗被砍下的头颅，我就付给他们五根黄铜棒。”好吧，我想大家的推测是，康拉德对帝国主义产生的日渐黑暗的看法很大程度上源于卡斯门特。所以卡斯门特加入了英国殖民地服务局，曾在非洲其他地方工作过。然后，在1901年，外交部把他作为英国领事派回了刚果。在去刚果之前，他去布鲁塞尔拜访了利奥波德国王。利奥波德国王说：“哦，太棒了。我希望你在刚果过得愉快，去布鲁塞尔拜访了利奥波德国王。利奥波德国王说：‘哦，太棒了。我希望你在刚果过得愉快。
If you've got any issues, come to me first. You know, if you saw anything wrong. I'm the father of the Congolese. Exactly. Casement goes to the Congo and quite clearly he's very disturbed by what he sees. He says it's beastly. He starts asking the Foreign Office if he can go on a fact-finding trip to the interior. And for various reasons, it doesn't happen. But then after this Commons debate, they say,
如果你有什么问题，首先来找我。你知道的，如果你发现有什么不对劲的地方。’我是刚果人的父亲。”完全正确。卡斯门特去了刚果，很显然，他对自己所看到的一切感到非常不安。他说这太畜生了。他开始向外交部请求是否能去内陆进行一次实地考察旅行。由于种种原因，这并未成行。但在此次下议院辩论之后，他们说：
okay, you can go, please go and find out what on earth is going on. So Casement goes off on this mission. He is not, I think it's fair to say, a happy or a well man. He's got malaria, he's got dysentery. He's also plagued. I'm sure you'll talk about this with John Banvolton. He's plagued by doubt and guilt because casement is gay and his sexuality is a kind of a torment to him in many ways. You know, he's got, has all these sorts of agonies of fear and doubt and whatnot. Anyway, he goes up river by steamboat. He spends three months in the interior.
“好吧，你可以去，请去查明那里到底发生了什么。”于是卡斯门特踏上了这次使命。我觉得可以公平地说，他并不是一个快乐或健康的人。他得了疟疾，患了痢疾。他还饱受折磨——我相信你会和约翰·班维尔谈到这一点，汤姆——他饱受怀疑和内疚的折磨，因为卡斯门特是同性恋，他的性取向在许多方面对他是种折磨。你知道的，他经历了所有这些关于恐惧和怀疑等等的痛苦煎熬。无论如何，他乘汽船逆流而上。他在内陆度过了三个月。
Uh, have've seen this, for company, he has a bulldog called John and he has a servant called Harry Bob and Harry Bob can cook only three dishes, chicken, custard and boiled sugar. Chicken and custard is delicious. Well, I mean, if you've got dysentery, is this the ideal diet? That's my question. No wonder his case was so miserable. So he goes into the interior and what he finds is even worse than he feared.
为了解闷，他带了一只叫约翰的斗牛犬，还有一个叫哈里·博布（Harry Bob）的仆人，而哈里·博布只会做三道菜：鸡肉、蛋羹和煮糖。鸡肉和蛋羹倒是挺美味的。好吧，我的意思是，如果你得了痢疾，这是理想的饮食吗？这就是我的问题。难怪他的情况如此悲惨。所以他深入内陆，而他所发现的甚至比他所担心的还要糟糕。
And we know this from his daily diary. The country a desert, no natives left. I walked into villages and saw the nearest one. Population dreadfully decreased. Only 93 people left out of many hundreds. And then a really sort of moving entry in his way. August the 30th, 16 men, women and children tied up from a village in Boyer, close to the town. Infamous. The men were put in the prison, the children let go at my intervention. Infamous, infamous, shameful system.
我们从他的日常日记中得知这一点：“国家犹如沙漠，没有剩下当地人。我走进村庄，看到最近的那个。人口急剧减少。几百人中只剩下93人。”接着是他日记中一段非常感人的记录：8月30日，“16名男女老少被从邻近城镇博耶（Boyer）的一个村庄捆绑带走。卑劣。在我的干预下，男人们被投入监狱，孩子们被释放。卑劣，卑劣，可耻的制度。”
Now all the time he is sending dispatches back to London and he says, oh, this is dreadful. Leopold has, and I quote, to put the natives on a path to their final extinction and the universal condemnation of civilized mankind. And you can well imagine the foreign office getting these thinking, Oh, come on. Oh no.
此后他一直向伦敦发送电报，他说：“哦，这太可怕了。利奥波德——我引述他的话——‘把当地人推向了最终灭绝的道路，并招致了文明人类的普遍谴责。’”你可以想象外交部收到这些电报时的反应：噢，拜托。噢，不。
Cause they don't want to cause a huge fuss. But also lurking in that sense of the shameful system, the infamous shameful system. I mean, is the system that he's talking about specifically the Belgian Congo, or is it the broader apparatus of imperialism per se? Exactly. And Casement is on a kind of journey, isn't he, that will lead him to condemn not just Leopold's empire in the Congo, but imperialism full stop.
因为他们不想惹出天大的麻烦。但在“可耻的制度、卑劣可耻的制度”这种感知背后，潜藏着的究竟是什么？我的意思是，他所谈论的制度究竟具体是指比利时刚果，还是更广泛的帝国主义机器本身？完全正确。卡斯门特正踏上一段旅程，不是吗？这段旅程将引领他不仅谴责利奥波德在刚果的帝国，而且谴责整个帝国主义。
Exactly. Exactly. Because that, of course, is the worry for the Foreign Office and for the British government generally, is that, you know, sure, look into the Congo free state, but stop there. You know, you shouldn't be looking into other colonies because of course, our colonies are perfect. Anyway, he gets back to London eventually, goes back to England in 1903. He writes his report. He actually finished the report coming home from a country house weekend with his old pal Joseph Conrad. Now his report is written in this kind of legalese. Hogg's Child describes it, I thought, in fascinating terms, the language that amnesty and similar groups would later make their own formal and sober, assessing the reliability of various witnesses filled with references to laws and statistics and accompanied by appendices and
完全正确。完全正确。因为这当然是外交部和英国政府普遍担忧的问题，你知道的，当然，去调查刚果自由邦，但到此为止。你知道，你不应该去调查其他殖民地，因为当然，我们的殖民地是完美的。无论如何，他最终回到了伦敦，于1903年回到英格兰。他写下了他的报告。实际上，他在结束了一次与老朋友约瑟夫·康拉德在乡村宅邸的周末度假、在回家的船上完成了这份报告。现在，他的报告是用这种法律条文般的语气写成的。霍格希尔（Hog's Child）对其进行了描述，我觉得用词非常迷人：“这种语言后来被国际特赦组织和其他类似组织奉为圭臬：正式而冷静，评估各种证人的可靠性，充斥着对法律和统计数据的引用，并附有附录和
depositions. And that's the key, isn't it? That it's not written in a tone of moral outrage. It's sober, cool, designed to appeal to bureaucrats and functionaries. But you mentioned the depositions. So the ND has kind of witness statements that go into all the horrors. And the Foreign Office are really shocked by the witness statements. The British ambassador to Belgium says. I can't believe that the Belgians would have done this. There are cultivated people even under a tropical sky. Surely the Belgians couldn't have lowered themselves to this.
证词。”这就是关键所在，不是吗？它不是用道德愤慨的语气写的。它是冷静、沉着的，旨在吸引官僚和官员。但你提到了证词。因此，ND（国家民主基金会/注：此处指国会/官方记录或相关档案）拥有某种深入各种恐怖事件的证人陈述。而外交部对这些证人陈述感到非常震惊。英国驻比利时大使表示：
Anyway this report is finally published. Britain sends copies at the beginning of 1904 to every signatory to the conference of Berlin. Even Leopold can't ignore this. I mean, this is a big story. And he says, well, I'll set up my own commission to investigate it. That's his usual ploy. And in the second half, we'll see how that turns out for him. But Casement is not yet finished. He now really has the zeal of a convert.
“我简直不敢相信比利时人会做出这种事。在热带天空下，也有知书达理的人。比利时人肯定不会自甘堕落到这种地步。”无论如何，这份报告终于发表了。英国在1904年初将副本发送给了柏林会议的每一位签字国。就连利奥波德也无法忽视这一点。我的意思是，这是一个大新闻。他说：“好吧，我自己成立一个委员会来调查此事。”这是他的惯用伎俩。在后半部分，我们将看到这对他的结局如何。但卡斯门特还没有结束。他现在真正拥有了皈依者的狂热。
He gets in touch with Morell. They have dinner in London and they talk until two o'clock in the morning. And Morel gave a wonderful, a wonderful vivid account of their first meeting, which I will read. He said, from the moment our hands gripped and our eyes met,
他与莫雷尔取得了联系。他们在伦敦共进晚餐，一直聊到凌晨两点。莫雷尔对他们的第一次会面做出了精彩、生动的描述，我将读出来。他说：“从我们双手紧握、四目相对的那一刻起，
mutual trust and confidence were bred and the feeling of isolation slipped from me like a mantle. Here was a man indeed, one who would convince those in high places of the foulness of the crime committed on a helpless race. Morel said in his memoir, you know, I often see him casement now in imagination as I saw him at that memorable interview crouching over the fire in the otherwise unlighted room, unfolding in a musical soft almost even voice in language of peculiar dignity and pathos the story of a vile conspiracy and as Casement talks in this beautiful voice of his Morel said I believe that I saw those hunted women
相互的信任和信心就滋生了，那种孤立感像一件斗篷一样从我身上滑落。这真是一个了不起的人，一个能够让位高权重者确信对一个无助种族犯下的罪行是何等丑恶的人。”莫雷尔在他的回忆录中写道：“你知道的，现在在想象中，我经常看到卡斯门特，就像我在那次难忘的会面中看到他那样，蜷缩在那个没有点灯的房间里的火炉旁，用一种音乐般柔和、几乎平缓的声音，用一种具有独特尊严和哀怨的语言，诉说着一个邪恶阴谋的故事。”而当卡斯门特用他那动听的声音讲述时，莫雷尔说，我相信我看到了那些被追捕的妇女
clutching their children flying panic-stricken to the bush the blood flowing the ghastly tally of severed heads and all this kind of thing you know Casement's Casement's skill as a storyteller is so important. This voice that everyone talks about. Exactly. Now Casement says to him that night and afterwards, look, I think we should set up a big new organization devoted to the Congo. And Casement says to him, you know, the Congo is different from other campaigns.
紧紧抱着他们的孩子，惊慌失措地逃向丛林，鲜血流淌，被砍下的人头的可怕统计数字，以及所有诸如此类的事情，你知道的，卡斯门特作为讲故事的人的技巧是如此重要。每个人都在谈论的这种声音。完全正确。现在卡斯门特在那天晚上以及之后对他说：“听着，我认为我们应该成立一个致力于刚果问题的大型新组织。”卡斯门特对他说：“你知道，刚果与其他运动不同。
The Congo is a unique evil. And if we can rouse the British people, the world might be roused. Britain had played that part before, meaning in the campaign against slavery, could we raise a throbbing in that great heart of hers? Right. This is a tremendous story. It's about kindness, but it's also how brilliant Britain is. But this is, I mean, will become the key point of divergence between Morel
刚果是一种独特的邪恶。如果我们能唤醒英国人民，世界也许就能被唤醒。”英国以前曾扮演过这种角色，指的是在反对奴隶制的运动中，我们能否唤醒她那伟大心脏中的悸动？没错。这是一个了不起的故事。它是关于善良的，但它也是关于英国是多么伟大。但这就是——我的意思是，这将成为莫雷尔
and Casement. Exactly. Because for Morel, Congo is sui generis. It's hideous. It has nothing to do with the broader imperial context. And Casement will come to a very different conclusion. Yeah. And listeners will discuss this in the bonus episode. Is the Congo unique or is the Congo symptomatic of the crimes of imperialism? And this is an issue for historians to this day. And indeed for moralists and theologians. Exactly. Ongoing debate at the moment. Very, very bitter debate, I think is fair to say.
与卡斯门特之间分歧的关键点。完全正确。因为对莫雷尔来说，刚果是独一无二的（sui generis）。它是丑陋的。它与更广泛的帝国主义背景毫无关系。而卡斯门特将得出截然不同的结论。是的。听众们将在加更节目中讨论这一点：刚果是独一无二的，还是帝国主义罪行的症状？这也是历史学家至今仍在争论的问题。当然，道德家和神学家们也是如此。完全正确。目前仍在进行激烈的辩论。我认为公平地说，这是一场非常非常激烈的辩论。
So anyway, Morell says, look, I mean, the new organization, I don't really have the money to set this up. Casement says, here's a check I think is fair to say. So anyway, Morell says, look, I mean, the new organisation, I don't really have the money to set this up. Casement says, here's a cheque for a hundred pounds, which he can't afford. It's more than a month salary for Casement, a lot of money. Morell uses this to buy a typewriter and the Congo Reform Association is born, one of the great human rights campaigning organisations. Now after this, Casement slightly drops out of the story.
所以无论如何，莫雷尔说，听着，我的意思是，这个新组织，我真的没有钱来筹备。凯斯门特说，这是一张支票，我觉得挺合适的。所以无论如何，莫雷尔说，听着，我的意思是，这个新组织，我真的没有钱来筹备。凯斯门特说，这里是一张一百英镑的支票，这是他拿不出来的钱。这比凯斯门特一个月的薪水还要多，是一大笔钱。莫雷尔用这笔钱买了一台打字机，刚果改革协会就这样诞生了，这是伟大的民权运动组织之一。接下来，凯斯门特在这段故事里就稍微淡出了。
The Foreign Office give him a promotion. They promote him to Consul in Lisbon. So off he goes to Portugal. Which he doesn't like because he finds it too civilised. Yes, too. It's boring. He and Morel are still great pals. They had a code, they had nicknames for each other.
外交部给了他一次升职。他们提拔他担任里斯本领事。于是他动身去了葡萄牙。但他其实并不喜欢那里，因为他觉得那里过于文明了。是的，太文明了。很无聊。他和莫雷尔依然是好哥们。他们之间有暗号，互相给对方起绰号。
So Casement was Tiger, Morel was Bulldog and Leopold was the King of Beasts. You see, I find that odd because I would have thought that Casement would be Bulldog because he's got John, his Bulldog. But Morel is more... He looks like a Bulldog. Yeah, he looks like a Bulldog and maybe there's a sort of patriotic thing there. You know, he's got a British Bulldog with his barrel chest. Maybe, but I think of John.
所以凯斯门特叫老虎，莫雷尔叫斗牛犬，而利奥波德则是野兽之王。你看，我觉得这很奇怪，因为我本以为凯斯门特会是斗牛犬，因为他有约翰，他的斗牛犬。但莫雷尔更像……他长得像斗牛犬。对，他长得像斗牛犬，也许这里面带有一种爱国情怀吧。你知道的，他胸膛宽厚，就像一只英国斗牛犬。也许吧，但我满脑子都是约翰。
Okay, I don't think Casement is a Tiger. If you're going to be an animal, Casement is not a Tiger. I think he's a puma. A puma? Yeah. Because he goes to South America and he's a kind of man of the shadows. Yes, I suppose.
好吧，我觉得凯斯门特不可能是老虎。如果要选一种动物，凯斯门特绝对不是老虎。我觉得他是一只美洲狮。美洲狮？对。因为他去过南美洲，而且他那种人就像隐匿于阴影之中。是的，我也这么觉得。
Yes, I can see that. Anyway, that's... But it's good to have a dog in the story. I love a dog on the rest of this history. We're very keen on dogs. So Morel throws himself into this new association. It has its first meeting in Liverpool, of course, the great shipping port in
对，我能理解。总之，那是……不过故事里能有一只狗挺好的。我喜欢这段历史其余部分里出现的狗。我们都非常喜欢狗。于是莫雷尔全身心投入到这个新协会中。它在利物浦召开了第一次会议，当然是在那个伟大的海运港口，时间是
1904 and it gets a thousand people. Now this is, it's slightly different from other human rights campaigns. And this is perhaps why it's more effective. It's a very establishment campaign. He has all kinds of endorsements from Earls and Viscounts, especially bishops. He loves a bishop and he loves an MP. Bishops, bishops very big in the anti-part He loves a bishop and he loves an MP. Bishop's very big in the anti-Party. Campaign.
1904年，有一千人出席。这有点不同，它与以往其他的民权运动有所不同。这也是它可能更有效的原因。这是一场非常主流的运动。他获得了来自伯爵、子爵，尤其是主教们的各种背书。他喜欢主教，他也喜欢国会议员。主教，主教在反派……哦不，他喜欢主教，他也喜欢国会议员。主教在反派运动中非常重要。运动。
Indeed. He loves an MP and he never, Morel never criticises the British empire or colonialism per se. He loves Britain. He loves Britain's empire. So that's not just a tactical move. He genuinely thinks Britain is top nation and also top nation for kindness. And that that's why Britain is peculiarly well equipped to lead this campaign. I think he genuinely thinks this.
确实如此。他喜欢国会议员，而且莫雷尔从来、从来没有批判过大英帝国或殖民主义本身。他热爱英国。他热爱大英帝国的。所以这不仅仅是一个战术策略。他是真心认为英国是顶尖国家，也是最善良的国家。正因如此，英国才格外具备领导这场运动的优势。我觉得他是真心这么想的。
And he is for somebody who basically was a shipping clerk, he turns out to be absolutely brilliant at running this campaign. He works incredibly hard. He writes 600 letters a month, which is 20 letters a day on average. He's a brilliant speaker. He will talk without notes to audiences of thousands, you know, week after week after week. He's great at tailoring his message to different audiences. So as a businessman, he will talk about Leopold's monopoly betrays free trade. To bishops, he says, it's our Christian duty.
对于一个原本只是船务文员的人来说，他证明了自己在领导这场运动方面简直天才横溢。他工作极其努力。他一个月写600封信，平均下来一天20封。他是个出色的演讲者。他可以在没有讲稿的情况下，面对成千上万的听众侃侃而谈，日复一日，周复一周。他非常擅长针对不同的听众调整自己的信息。因此，面对商人时，他会谈论利奥波德的垄断背叛了自由贸易。而面对主教时，他会说这是我们的基督教责任。
To audiences of the sort of common people, he says, it's Britain's responsibility as top nation to lead the world. He always makes sure he has MPs from different parties sitting on the platform, as well as all the local bigwigs. He's great at wooing rich supporters. So the Cadbury's Chocolate Family, we did a podcast about them last year. They're Quakers. They see themselves as great philanthropists. He gets loads of donations from them. He likes a celebrity.
面对普通大众的听众时，他会说，作为顶尖国家，领导世界是英国的责任。他总是确保演讲台上坐着来自不同政党的国会议员，以及所有当地的名流。他非常擅长讨好富有的支持者。比如吉百利巧克力家族，我们去年做过一档关于他们的播客。他们是贵格会教徒。他们将自己视为伟大的慈善家。他从他们那里得到了大量的捐款。他喜欢名人。
So Sir Arthur Conan Doyle, the Sherlock Holmes creator, he gets Conan Doyle to rallies, he gets him to write his own book on the Congo, the crime of the Congo. I mean, the thing about that is Conan Doyle is very keen say on the war against the birds in South Africa that the British are fighting. I mean, the thing about that is Conan Doyle is very keen, say, on the war against the birds in South Africa that the British are fighting. So he sees no contradiction between supporting British imperialism in South Africa and excoriating Belgian imperialism in the Congo. What a perfect recruit.
所以亚瑟·柯南·道尔爵士，福尔摩斯的创造者，他把柯南·道尔请到了集会上，他还让柯南·道尔写了一本关于刚果的书，《刚果的罪行》。我的意思是，关于这一点，柯南·道尔非常热衷于，比如说，英国在南非打击那些鸟类的战争……我的意思是，关于这一点，柯南·道尔非常热衷于，比如说，英国在南非打击那些鸟类的战争。所以他认为支持英国在南非的帝国主义和痛斥比利时在刚果的帝国主义之间并不矛盾。多么完美的招募对象啊。
Probably the most famous writer of the day. Very patriotic. You know, you can't write him off as a do gooding, bleeding hearted, you know, he loves a campaigning cause Conan Doyle, but there's no doubt that he also loves Britain. So the perfect, perfect person to have. And Morel also knows the value of the modern image. So it's Morel who really pioneers the use of slideshows with all these pictures of people with their hands cut off. And this is in a way the highlight of his rallies.
可能是当时最著名的作家了。非常爱国。你知道的，你不能把他贬低为一个只会做好事、心软的……你知道的，柯南·道尔热爱这种政治运动，但毫无疑问他也热爱英国。所以他是最完美、最合适的人选。而且莫雷尔也深知现代影像的价值。所以正是莫雷尔真正开创了幻灯片的先河，里面全都是人们被砍断手的人的照片。从某种程度上讲，这是他集会上的高潮。
It's the bit that everyone's been waiting for and everyone will remember. He shows them the pictures and that's the thing that really, really has an effect. A.J.P. Taylor, the great historian, himself from a dissenting background said that Morrell was in his view, the single best, most effective activist, most effective leader of a campaign in British history. And I don't think he's wrong actually. I mean, the thing is that he is kind of going with the grain of British public opinion. Part of their patriotism is a sense that, you know, this is the country that abolished
这是所有人一直在等待、也所有人都会记住的部分。他向他们展示这些照片，这才是真正、真正产生影响的东西。A·J·P·泰勒，这位伟大的历史学家，他本人有着异见背景，曾表示在他看来，莫雷尔是英国历史上最出色、最有效率的活动家，也是最伟大的运动领导者。我觉得他其实并没有说错。我的意思是，关键在于他某种程度上顺应了英国公众舆论的主流。他们的爱国主义的一部分是一种信念，即你知道，这个国家废除了
the slave trade. They're on the side of the angels, all of that. But in government, there is still a kind of a slight cynicism, a slightly more Machiavellian approach to things. So there's a Belgian newspaper editor who was quoted by Huxley who once shrewdly remarked that Lord Salisbury, who was Prime Minister throughout much of this period, is, and I quote, is not a man to care much about the fate of the blacks any more than that of the Armenians or the Bulgarians. And Morel himself writing about Sir Edward Grey, Foreign Secretary, of course, in the buildup to the- Great hero of yours, Tom.
奴隶贸易。他们站在正义的一边，诸如此类。但在政府内部，仍然存在着一种轻微的冷嘲热讽，对事情采取了一种更加马基雅维利式的方法。所以有一位比利时报纸编辑，曾被赫胥黎引用过，他曾精辟地评论说，在这一时期的很大一部分时间里担任首相的索尔兹伯里勋爵，他——我引述一下——“并不是一个会过多关心黑人命运的人，就像他不会关心亚美尼亚人或保加利亚人的命运一样”。而莫雷尔本人在谈到外交大臣爱德华·灰色爵士时，当然是在……
Great hero of mine, great fisherman, great bird watcher. However, Morel does say of Sir Edward Grey that he would act only when kicked. And if the process of kicking is stopped, he will do nothing. And basically Morel sees it as his job to do that kicking. But as kickers go, he's probably the best kicker or one of the best kickers. The Johnny Wilkinson of moral kicking. And not just in Britain. So by the middle of the 1900s, there are branches of his association in France and Germany, in the countries of Scandinavia,
你的大英雄，汤姆。我的大英雄，伟大的渔夫，伟大的观鸟者。然而，莫雷尔确实说过，对于爱德华·灰色爵士，只有遭到踢打时他才会采取行动。如果踢打的过程停下来，他将什么也不会做。基本上，莫雷尔将踢打这事视为自己的工作。但如果要说踢打者，他可能是最棒的踢打者，或者说其中最棒的踢打者之一。道德踢打界的小约翰·威尔金森。而且不仅在英国。因此到了20世纪00年代中期，他的协会在法国和德国、斯堪的纳维亚国家都有了分支机构，
in Switzerland, in Australia, in New Zealand. And he has put the issue of the Congo Free State on the front pages of newspapers in almost every country on earth. So the question is, is this enough to trouble Leopold? How will the king fight back? Can I just read what you've put in your notes? The concluding question. So just a quote. This is what you've written, Dominic. So the tide seems to be turning, but will this be enough to trouble Leopold? How will he fight back? And how does it involve one of the, and now capitals, fattest men in history?
在瑞士、澳大利亚、新西兰都有。他把刚果自由邦的问题推上了地球上几乎所有国家报纸的头版。所以问题是，这足以让利奥波德感到头疼吗？国王将如何反击？我能读一下你写在笔记里的内容吗？总结性的问题。也就是一段引言。这是你写的，多米尼克。所以局势似乎正在转变，但这足以让利奥波德感到头疼吗？他将如何反击？这又如何牵涉到历史上身材最胖的——这里是大写字母——男人之一？
The fattest men in history. Come back after the break to meet this extraordinary man. These meddlesome American missionaries. These frank British consuls. These blabbing Belgian-born traitor officials, those tiresome parrots are always talking. They have told how for twenty years I have ruled the Congo state, seizing and holding the state as my personal property, the whole of its vast revenues as my private swag.
历史上最胖的男人。休息一下，回来认识这位非凡的人物。这些爱管闲事的美国传教士。这些坦率的英国领事。这些大嘴巴的出生于比利时的叛徒官员，那些讨厌的鹦鹉总是说个不停。他们讲述了我二十年来是如何统治刚果邦的，将这个国家据为己有并牢牢抓在手中，将其庞大的全部收入当作我个人的战利品。
Mine, solely mine, claiming and holding its millions of people as my private property, my serfs, my slaves, the robber, the ivory and all the other riches of the land, mine, mine solely, and gassed for me by the men, the women and the little children, and a compulsion of lash and bullet, fire, starvation, mutilation, and the altar. These pests, they have kept nothing back. They have revealed these and yet other details which shame should have kept them silent about, since they were exposures of a king, a sacred personage and immune from reproach by right of his appointment to his great office by God himself.
属于我，仅仅属于我，将数以百万计的人民宣称为并当作我的私有财产、我的农奴、我的奴隶，掠夺象牙以及这片土地上所有其他的财富，全部归我，仅归我所有，并通过男人、女人和幼童为我榨取，在皮鞭和子弹、烈火、饥饿、残割以及祭坛的强力逼迫下。这些讨厌鬼，他们什么都没隐瞒。他们揭露了这些以及其他本该因羞耻而保持沉默的细节，因为这些是对一位国王、一位神圣人物的曝光，而凭借上帝本人对他的伟大职位的任命权，他免于受到指责。
So that was King Leopold II, King of the Belgians, as ventriloquized by Mark Twain in his satirical monologue King Leopold's Soliloquy, which he published in 1905. Mark Twain, of course, one of the greatest American writers and we've already had a lot of great writers in this series, but it's good to get Twain in, isn't it? Definitely. So we'll come to Twain in a little bit because Twain joins the campaign against the Congo Free State.
这就是利奥波德二世国王，比利时人的国王，由马克·吐温在他1905年出版的讽刺独白《利奥波德国王的独白》中进行了腹语般的演绎。马克·吐温，当然是美国最伟大的作家之一，我们在这个系列中已经介绍过很多伟大的作家了，但能把吐温也囊括进来真是不错，对吧？确实如此。所以我们等一会儿就会讲到吐温，因为吐温加入了反对刚果自由邦的运动。
But first of all, well, how's Leopold? How's he reacted to all this? I mean, I think it's fair to say he probably does think what the words that Twain has put into his mouth. Leopold is now, he turned 60 in 1895. He's a very rich man, but he's very unpopular in Belgium. He has all these villas on the French Riviera. He's got a massive yacht. He spends a lot of his time in the south of France. A lot of Belgians say to themselves, well, he's got this massive colony, all this money, but we're not seeing any benefits from it. Dominic, what about his love life? Well, he's disgraced himself, I think.
但首先，嗯，利奥波德怎么样了？他是如何对这一切做出反应的？我的意思是，我觉得可以公平地说，他大概真的在想吐温塞进他嘴里的那些话。利奥波德现在，他在1895年迎来了60岁生日。他是个非常富有的人，但在比利时却极不受欢迎。他在法国里维埃拉拥有多栋别墅。他有一艘巨大的游艇。他的大部分时间都在法国南部度过。许多比利时人心里都在想，嗯，他拥有这么庞大的殖民地，有这么多钱，但我们却没有从中获得任何好处。多米尼克，他的感情生活怎么样？嗯，我想他已经身败名裂了。
He's let Belgium down. So he has got this new mistress who is exceedingly controversial. She's a young French prostitute called Caroline de Lacroix or Lacroix, the different versions of her name. They probably met when he was 65 and she was 16. They probably met at a brothel or hotel in Paris. And am I right that she was probably pimped by a guy who'd been her lover? That's right. Who's a former soldier called Antoine Emmanuel Durieu. And as we will see, he remains very much on the scene.
他让比利时失望了。所以他找了一个新的情妇，此人极其具有争议。她是一个年轻的法国妓女，名叫卡洛琳·德·拉克鲁瓦或拉克鲁瓦（名字有不同的拼写版本）。他们可能是在他65岁、她16岁时相识的。他们很可能是在巴黎的一家妓所或酒店相识的。我没记错的话，她很可能是被一个曾是她情人的家伙当成妓女拉皮条的吧？正是如此。那是一个前士兵，名叫安托万·埃曼纽尔·迪里厄。正如我们将看到的，他依然留在现场。
He's always lurking in the background, adding to the general quality of moral property. Now, Leopold's wife, who he of course he hated, died in 1902, and he now becomes completely obsessed with Caroline. He installed her near his castle at Lacken outside Brussels. He spent millions of francs on jewels and clothes for her. He gave her a retinue of servants. I mean, disgracefully, Tom, he took her with him to Queen Victoria's funeral, which was a shocking, enormous scandal. She bore him two children in 1909 and 1910. And actually, far more than the issue
他总是潜伏在背景中，为道德败坏的整体品质添砖加瓦。现在，利奥波德的妻子——他当然恨她——于1902年去世了，他现在对卡洛琳变得完全着迷。他在布鲁塞尔郊外拉肯的城堡附近为她安了家。他在她身上花了数百万法郎的珠宝和衣服。他为她配备了一支随从队伍。我的意思是，汤姆，真是不成体统，他竟然带着她去参加维多利亚女王的葬礼，这是一桩令人震惊的弥天丑闻。她在1909年和1910年为他生了两个孩子。事实上，比起
of the Congo Free State, this is what destroys his reputation in Belgium. But the two issues become slightly conflated in the world's press. So when her second son was born, there was some issue with his hand. I'm not exactly sure what it was, but whether he had a withered arm or what it was,
刚果自由邦的问题，这才是真正摧毁他在比利时声誉的事情。但这这两个问题在世界的报刊上有些混淆了。所以当她的第二个儿子出生时，他的手出了一些问题。我不太确定具体是什么问题，是他手臂萎缩了还是别的什么，
but anyway, there's an issue with his hand and punch magazine in England, then very, very popular published a cartoon showing Leopold holding this baby with a kind of injured hand and he's surrounded by African corpses with severed hands. And the caption says vengeance from on high. In other words, God has punished you for what you've done to these people. That's pretty punchy. Yeah. Well, literally, literally. words, God has punished you for what you've done to these people. That's pretty punchy. Yeah. Well, literally, literally.
但总之，他的手出了问题，英国的《笨拙》杂志（当时非常非常受欢迎）发表了一幅漫画，画的是利奥波德抱着这个手部受伤的婴儿，周围全是被砍断了手的非洲尸体。标题写着“来自高处的复仇”。换句话说，上帝因为你对这些人所做的一切而惩罚了你。这可真够辛辣的。对啊。字面意思，字面意思。上帝因为你对这些人所做的一切而惩罚了你。这可真够辛辣的。对啊。字面意思，字面意思。
Yeah, exactly. So now Leopold is very upset by all this, of course, and he does something very modern. He employs a PR campaign of his own. They place articles in the newspapers about abuses in British colonies. IE he's saying, you are the most dreadful hypocrites. You think I'm bad. Look at what you're doing in Nigeria or Sierra Leone or Africa. He's got a point. Well, we'll discuss whether he's got a point in the bonus episode, but it's fair to say,
对，完全如此。所以现在利奥波德对这一切感到非常沮丧，这是当然的，于是他做了一件非常现代的事情。他雇用了属于他自己的公关活动。他们在报纸上发表关于英国殖民地虐待行为的文章。也就是说，他在说，你们是最可怕的伪君子。你们觉得我很坏。看看你们在尼日利亚、塞拉利昂或非洲所做的事。他确实说到了点子上。好吧，我们将在番外篇中讨论他是否真的说到了点子上，但可以公平地说，
I think it's absolutely fair to say all European empires have skeletons rattling around in their closets. He's not wrong about that. That's for sure. He gets his tame shipping companies to sponsor books and articles. He sets up lobby groups with, I mean, all of these sort of comical names, the committee for the protection of interest in Africa, the Federation for the Defense of Belgian Interests Abroad, you know, all of these groups that again, sound very contemporary, don't they? I mean, the kind of thing you see all the time. Well, it's what South Africa did during the apartheid campaign. Of course.
我想完全可以公平地说，所有欧洲帝国的心里都藏着不可告人的秘密。在这件事上他并没有说错。那是肯定的。他让那些受他控制的航运公司资助书籍和文章。他建立游说集团，我的意思是，所有这些听起来很滑稽的名字，“非洲利益保护委员会”、“保卫比利时海外利益联合会”，你知道的，所有这些组织再次听起来非常具有当代感，不是吗？我的意思是，你随时都能看到的那种。好吧，这就是南非在反种族隔离运动期间所做的事。当然。
And I suppose it's also to a degree kind of what big tobacco or big oil tend to do. Of course it is. Of course it is. They subsidize magazines, which he does. He has a magazine called New Africa, the truth about the Congo Free State. You know, that, that these, this is classic, you know, it's so common now, but at the time it is groundbreaking. And he spends a lot of money on journalists. And then we know about this because we have the paper trail of his attempts to bribe the German press. Entertainingly, his chief agent in Germany, who was a guy called Ludwig van Stoib, claimed that the Belgians were very slow about handing over, about reimbursing him for his costs.
我想这也某种程度上类似于大型烟草公司或大型石油公司往往会做的事情。当然是的。当然是的。他们资助杂志，他确实这么做过。他有一本杂志叫《新非洲：关于刚果自由邦的真相》。你知道的，这些，这是经典的运作方式，现在太常见了，但在当时却是开创性的。他在记者身上花了很多钱。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们保留了他试图收买德国媒体的纸质证据。有趣的是，他在德国的主管，一个名叫路德维希·冯·施托伊布的家伙，声称比利时人在支付费用和报销开销方面非常拖沓。
And he wrote to Brussels and said, where's my reimbursement? And he said, now you'll keep asking me for receipts. Obviously I don't have any receipts because I'm giving people cash, brown envelopes or whatever. By the way, one issue for Leopold is that our old friend, the Kaiser in Germany, the Kaiser absolutely despises Leopold. He called him Satan and Mammon in one person. Will Barron Is this the same Kaiser who is leading the country that is simultaneously practicing genocide in Namibia? Alistair Duggan That's the man.
他写信给布鲁塞尔说，我的报销在哪里？对方回答说，你现在一直跟我要收据。很显然我没有任何收据，因为我给的是现金，黄色信封什么的。顺便说一句，利奥波德面临的一个问题是，我们的老朋友，德国的德皇，德皇对利奥波德极其鄙视。他称他为“集撒旦与财神于一身”。威利·巴伦：这是那个同时在纳米比亚实行种族灭绝的国家的德皇吗？阿拉斯泰尔·达根：正是此人。
Will Barron Right. Alistair Duggan Okay. Alistair Duggan Yeah. I think there's a fair bit of double standards. Will Barron Hot kettle? Alistair D this. Exactly. Now the battle moves in about 1904 to America. America of course was the first country to recognize the Congo free state. It's a bit of an embarrassment.
威利·巴伦：好吧。阿拉斯泰尔·达根：行吧。阿拉斯泰尔·达根：对。我觉得这里面有相当多的双重标准。威利·巴伦：五十步笑百步？阿拉斯泰尔·达根：正是如此。现在，斗争在1904年左右转移到了美国。美国当然是第一个承认刚果自由邦的国家。这有点尴尬。
Do you think? Yes, I think so. And Edmund D. Morell says, you know, the United States has a special responsibility to, to, to address this because they are the country that basically opened the door to Leopold getting this territory. But also, as in the abolitionist movement, that there is a kind of congruity, a moral congruity between British and American takes on this. Absolutely. So missionaries will often do tours, speaking tours, British missionaries in America, American
你觉得呢？是的，我也这么认为。埃德蒙·D·莫雷尔说，你知道的，美国对此负有特殊的责任去解决这个问题，因为正是美国打开了让利奥波德获得这片领土的大门。但同样，正如在废奴运动中一样，英国和美国对此的看法之间存在着一种一致性，一种道德上的一致性。绝对如此。所以传教士们经常会进行巡回演讲，在美国的英国传教士，在英国的美国
missionaries in Britain. There was a sense of, dare I say, a special relationship, a sort of moral relationship on this front. So in 1904, Morell goes to America. He meets Theodore Roosevelt at the White House. He recruits Mark Twain. Twain is then in his 60s. He's probably the most famous author in America. He's all in on the campaign.
传教士。有一种——我敢说——特殊关系的感觉，在这条战线上存在着某种道德关系。所以在1904年，莫雷尔去了美国。他在白宫会见了西奥多·罗斯福。他招募了马克·吐温。当时的吐温已经60多岁了。他可能是美国最著名的作家。他全身心地投入到了这场运动中。
And he's a man who knows the world. I mean, he's been around the world. He's seen, he can absolutely understand how this could happen. And he's a great activist. He's a great campaigner, Twain. He goes to Washington three times to lobby the president, to lobby Congress. And it becomes this huge crusade. Petitions signed by thousands of people, by governors, by senators, university presidents and so on. Now Leopold, again, doesn't take this lying down. He fights back. He mounts a lobbying campaign in America. He offers Congo concessions to the Guggenheim family, to John D. Rockefeller. He gives artifacts to the American Museum of Natural History
他是一个了解世界的人。我的意思是，他走遍了世界。他亲眼所见，他完全能够理解这一切是如何发生的。而且他是一个伟大的活动家。他是一个伟大的倡导者，吐温。他三次前往华盛顿去游说总统，游说国会。这就成了一场巨大的十字军东征。成千上万的人、州长、参议员、大学校长等都在请愿书上签了名。现在利奥波德同样没有坐视不管。他进行了反击。他在美国发起了一场游说运动。他向古根海姆家族、约翰·D·洛克菲勒提供刚果的特许权。他向美国自然历史博物馆捐赠文物，
because he knows that J.P. Morgan is on the board and he pays American academics to defend him. So to give you just one example, a guy called Frederick Starr from the University of Chicago, he's paid by Leopold to write a series of articles for the Chicago Tribune called The Truth About the Congo Free State. But then Leopold makes a terrible mistake and Tom, we promised a very large man and now he rumbles, he looms into view. How large is he? Just so we get that he's established. He's about 21 stone. I don't know what that is in American measurements. So you've, so heavy, one journalist said he made President Taft look like a top worker in a team of acrobats. Exactly.
因为他知道J·P·摩根是董事会成员，他还花钱请美国学者为他辩护。举个例子，芝加哥大学一个叫弗雷德里克·斯塔尔的家伙，被利奥波德收买，为《芝加哥论坛报》撰写了一系列名为《关于刚果自由邦的真相》的文章。但随后利奥波德犯了一个可怕的错误，汤姆，我们答应过有一个非常魁梧的巨汉，现在他轰隆隆地、隐约地进入了我们的视野。他有多胖？为了让我们明白他的确立。他大约有21英石重。我不知道这按美制单位是多少。所以你，太重了，有个记者说他让塔夫特总统看起来像杂技团队里的顶级杂技演员。没错。
President Taft is famously large. He's the fattest president in American history and this bloke makes Taft look like a kind of gymnast. Like a sylph. Exactly. So this guy is called Colonel, I mean you couldn't make it up, he's called Colonel Henry I Kowalski. And Leopold takes him on as his chief lobbyist and pays him the equivalent of about a million
塔夫特总统以体型庞大闻名。他是美国历史上最胖的总统，而这家伙让塔夫特看起来像个体操运动员。像个林中仙女一样。没错。所以这家伙叫上校，我的天，你简直编都编不出来，他叫亨利·I·科瓦尔斯基上校。利奥波德聘请他担任自己的首席说客，付给他的薪水相当于当今每年大约一百万美元，即十万法郎。现在科瓦尔斯基有一系列的问题。第一，他是个彻头彻尾的骗子。第二，他患有发作性嗜睡症。所以，这可能与汤姆你所说的他的肥胖有关。因此他会毫无征兆地睡着。他是个律师。他会在法庭上睡着。他在酒店大堂等候与人会面时会睡着。我还读到过，他甚至会在街上睡着。所以他走在街上走着走着就会睡着。嗯，我不知道他会怎么样，他是还站着呢还是会摔倒？
dollars a year today, 100,000 francs. Now Kowalski has a series of problems. One, he's a total fraud. And two, he's a narcoleptic. So, and this may be related, I think, Tom, to his fatness. So he will fall asleep unexpectedly. He's a lawyer. He'll fall asleep in court. He falls asleep when he's waiting to meet people in hotel lobbies. And he also, I read, falls asleep in the street. So he'll be like walking down the street or something. And well, I don't know what does he, is he still standing up? Is he fall over?
我的意思是，他是个大块头。羊不是站着睡觉的吗？站着睡，没错。所以你希望他不会摔倒。那是一种震颤。是的。在纽约街头回响。总之，比利时大使听说利奥波德雇了这家伙时，说道，什么？这个人
I mean, he's a large man. Don't sheep go to sleep standing up? Standing up, exactly. So you'd hope that he wouldn't fall. They're sort of tremors. Yes. Echoing across New York. Anyway, the Belgian ambassador, when he hears that Leopold has employed this guy, says, what? This man
是个臭名昭著的骗子。别介，我们在搞什么名堂？所以基本上，在第一年过后，比利时人就没有续签这个科瓦尔斯基的合同。你知道的，其实，不，我们改变主意了。科瓦尔斯基在没有睡着的时候，对此感到愤怒。你知道他做了什么吗？他直接去找了报业大亨威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特，他说，我一直受雇担任比利时第二位国王的付费说客。你想听这个故事吗？令利奥波德惊恐的是，在1906年12月，赫斯特旗下的报纸之一《纽约美国人报》在头版打出了醒目的大标题：“利奥波德国王企图影响我国国会的惊天阴谋曝光”。
is a notorious fraud. Like, don't, what are we doing? So basically, after the first year, the Belgians don't renew this guy Kowalski's contract. You know, actually, no, we've changed our minds. Kowalski, when he's not asleep, is outraged by this. And do you know what he does? He goes straight to the newspaper baron, William Randolph Hearst, and he says, I've been working as a paid lobbyist for a king of the second of Belgium. Would you like the story? And to Leopold's horror, in December 1906, the New York American, one of Hearst's papers, banner headline on its front page, King Leopold's amazing attempt to influence our Congress exposed.
科瓦尔斯基把一切都告诉了他们，包括他一直在收买参议院外交关系委员会的一名工作人员，以蓄意破坏国会对刚果问题的决议。连续一个星期的每一天，赫斯特旗下的报纸头条都关于刚果。被砍断的手的照片、令人震惊的传教士陈述，应有尽有。这是一个巨大的新闻。基本上，这一切结束时，利奥波德已经彻底失去了美国公众舆论的支持。因为我记得当那场运动发起时，它导致美国成为第一个承认利奥波德对刚果管辖权的国家，当时有人说，哦，他就是那种能给国王带来好名声的人。对。
And Kowalski has told them everything, including the fact that he's been paying a staffer on the Senate Foreign Relations Committee to basically derail congressional resolutions on the Congo. And for every day for a week, Hearst's papers lead with the Congo. Pictures of the severed hands, shocking missionary accounts, the works. It's a massive story. And basically, by the time it's all over, Leopold has comprehensively lost American public opinion. Because I remember when that campaign is launched that leads to the United States being the first country to recognise Leopold's jurisdiction over the Congo, there was somebody said, oh, he's the kind of person who gives kings a good name. Yeah.
但假设他是个国王这一事实，实际上只会让他在美国人眼里显得更加糟糕。是的，一个邪恶、腐败的欧洲国王。我的意思是，他是最完美的恶棍，不是吗？带着他那大约12岁的情妇什么的。我的意思是，这是一个可怕的……我认为公平地说，他是欧洲殖民主义的一个极其糟糕的负面典型。所以利奥波德现在可能只剩下一张牌了。
But presumably the fact that he is a king actually just makes him seem even worse in American eyes. Yeah, an evil, corrupt European king. I mean, he's the perfect villain, isn't he? With his sort of 12-year-old mistress or whatever she is. I mean, it's a terrible... He is a very bad standard para for European colonialism, I think it's fair to say. So Leopold has probably only one card left now.
还记得他曾建立过一个微型的伪造委员会来调查凯斯门特报告吗？这个委员会由三名法官组成。其中一名是意大利人，一名是比利时人，还有一名是瑞士人。利奥波德相当自信他们会听话，因为那个意大利人已经在刚果担任他的首席上诉法院法官了。所以他想，好吧，能出什么岔子呢？然而令人难以置信且完全令他惊恐的是，法官们竟然把这当回事了。
Remember that he had set up one of his little fake commissions to investigate the casement report. So this has three judges on it. There's one Italian, there's one Belgian, and there's one Swiss. And Leopold is pretty confident that they will fall into line because the Italian bloke already works in the Congo as his chief appeal court judge. So he thinks, well, what could possibly go wrong? And unbelievably to his complete horror, the judges, they take it far too seriously.
他们说，好吧，我们显然要去刚果调查那些虐待行为。这就好比，你知道的……哦不，他们坐着蒸汽船溯河而上，约瑟夫·康拉德式的风格。他们与400名目击者进行了交谈。他们与遭到过奇科特皮鞭抽打的非洲人交谈。他们与被当作人质关押的人交谈，诸如此类的事情。与此同时，利奥波德潜伏回了布鲁塞尔，等待他们的报告。然后他们开始，他开始听到谣言说，其中一位法官——我们不知道是哪一位——在采访过程中哭了起来，因为这些故事而深受感动。
They say, well, we'll obviously go to the Congo and we'll investigate the abuses. It's like, you know, Oh no, they go up the river by steamboat, Joseph Conrad style. They talked to 400 witnesses. They talk to Africans who've been flogged with the chicot. They talk to people who've been held hostage, all of this kind of thing. Leopold, meanwhile, is back lurking back in Brussels, waiting for their report. And they start, he starts to hear rumors that one of the judges, we don't know which one, has started crying during the interviews has been so moved by
这对利奥波德来说是个非常不好的征兆。然后是个可怕的征兆。法官们回来了，他们去向总督汇报。那是利奥波德维尔。我猜当时是在利奥波德维尔。或者是最初的首都博马，我不确定到底是哪个。这个人叫科斯塔曼斯先生。他们去向他汇报他们的调查结果。当他们离开科斯塔曼斯的办公室时，
the stories. That's a very bad sign for Leopold. Then a terrible sign. The judges come back and they go to brief the governor general. So that's in Leopoldville. I guess it's in Leopoldville at this point. Or Boma, the original capital, I'm not sure which. This is a guy called Mr Costamans. They go to brief him about their findings. Costamans, when they leave Costamans' office,
科斯塔曼斯震惊得好几天都没和任何人说话。然后两周后，他用剃刀割断了自己的喉咙自杀了。我的意思是，有趣的是，这似乎真的震惊了他。好吧，当然了，如果他是总督的话，他大概连逆流而上深入内陆去
Costamans is so shocked that he doesn't speak to anybody for days. And then two weeks later, he cuts his throat with a razor and kills himself. I mean, it's interesting that it seems genuinely to have shocked him. Well, of course, if he's the governor general, he probably hasn't even gone upriver into the interior
看看那里发生了什么都没有过。但我得到的印象是，那里的每个人都知道发生了什么。我认为有些人可能在其中工作，作为公务员，可能只是闭上了眼睛。你觉得呢？我不知道。他或许，在某种程度上，
and seen what's going on. But the impression I've had is that everybody there knows what's going on. I think there are people who probably work in the, who are, as it were, civil servants, who perhaps have just closed their eyes. Do you think? I don't know. He perhaps, in part of it,
我认为这在历史上很常见。有些人在内心深处，他们其实知道发生了什么，但他们把那扇门关上了。也许是内疚。也许是内疚。是的，还有震惊。我不知道。所以这份报告于1905年11月发表。同样，这是一份非常具有法律风格的报告，一点也不耸人听闻。个人的证词没有被公开，也就是目击者的证词。直到20世纪80年代，这些证词才对研究人员开放。但它们确实保留了刚果人的声音。
I think it's very common in history. You have people who are part of their mind. They kind of know what's going on, but they've closed that door. Maybe it's guilt. Maybe it's guilt. Yeah. As well as shock. I don't know. So the report came out in November 1905. And again, it's a very lawyerly kind of report, not sensational at all. The individual statements were not released, the witness statements. They actually weren't open to researchers until the 1980s. But they do preserve the voices of the Congolese.
所以在整个故事中，我们一直在说我们没有这些声音，但现在我们确实有了。是的。汤姆，你想读几个节选，让大家感受一下吗？好的。所以你没有收录最令人震惊的部分，但这里有一些风味。所以他是在谈论一个官员。他告诉他的哨兵把我们绑在两棵树上，我们的脚离地。我们的手臂举过头顶。我们这样被吊了好几天几夜。当
So throughout this story, we've been saying we haven't got them, but now we do have them. Yeah. Do you want to read a couple of extracts, Tom, to give people a sense of it? Yeah. So you've not included the most shocking, but here's a flavour. So he's talking about an official. He told his sentries to tie us to two trees with our feet off the ground. Our arms were stretched over our heads. We were hanging in this way several days and nights. Whilst
我们挂在那里的时候，三个哨兵和白人男子用又硬又大的棍子殴打我们的私处、脖子和其他身体部位，直到我们昏厥过去。当我年纪很小的时候，士兵们因为橡胶的原因来我的村庄打仗。士兵用刀砍断了我的右手并把它拿走了。所以，再次证明了活人被砍断手的证词。这不仅仅是尸体。我看到他带着其他被砍断的手。同一天，我的父亲和母亲被杀了，我知道他们的手也被砍断了。所以，我的意思是，活着的，死去的，全都是关于手。然后是最后一条。
we hung there, three sentries and the white man beat us in the private parts on the neck and other parts of the body with big hard sticks till we fainted. When I was very small, the soldiers came to make war in my village because of the rubber. The soldier used a knife to cut off my right hand and took it away. So again, there is testimony to living people having their hands cut off. It's not just corpses. I saw that he was carrying other cut off hands. The same day my father and mother were killed and I know that they had their hands cut off. So, I mean, living dead, it's all about the hands. And then a final one.
我很了解容吉，白人抓着他的头。好吧，尼科伊站在他的脚边，用手杖打他。最后，尼科伊踢了容吉好几下，叫他起来。当他不动时，阿卡特对白人说，这个人死了。你把他弄死了。白人回答说，我才不在乎呢。法官和我一样都是白人。难怪他们在比利时把这些藏起来。所以那份报告确实是利奥波德最后一次企图重新掌握叙事权的机会，显然他彻底失败了。到了这个时候，他已经变成了一个比以往任何时候都更加怪诞的人物。
I knew Jungi well, the white man held his head. Well, Nikoi standing at his feet, hit him with a cane. Finally, Nikoi kicked Jungi several times and told him to get up. When he didn't move, Akate said to the white man, this man is dead. You've killed him. The white man replied, I don't give a damn. The judges are white men like me. So no wonder they kept them hidden in Belgium. So that report really was Leopold's last chance to recapture the narrative and obviously he completely failed. By this point, he's become an even more grotesque figure than
他已经七十出头了。他是一个严重的疑病症患者。他骑着一辆巨大的三轮车在比利时到处转悠，喝着他认为对健康有益的热水壶里的热水。比利时每个人都恨他。一旦科瓦尔斯基的丑闻在美国曝光，接着又爆出那些由他自己驯服的法官写出的报告，他意识到大势已去。基本上在这个时候，他意识到我得摆脱刚果了，而且我想把我的钱拿回来。
ever. He's in his early seventies. He's a massive hyperchondriac. He's riding around Belgium on a gigantic tricycle, drinking decanters of hot water, which he thinks are good for his health. Everyone in Belgium hates him. And once this Kowalski business comes out in America and then the reports, obviously by his own tame judges, he realizes the game is up. And effectively at this point, he realizes I'm going to have to get rid of the Congo and I want my money back.
于是他决定把它卖给比利时国家。这当然是一开始他最不想做的事。现在，不幸的是，对于我们这些想看到正义得以伸张的人来说，利奥波德在这里处于非常强势的地位。这对比利时来说是可怕的公关灾难。多米尼克，我的意思是，必须要说的是，有很多比利时人也一直在参与这场运动，有很多期刊、很多杂志、很多报纸。
And so he decides he's going to sell it to the Belgian state. The one thing, of course, that at the beginning he didn't want to do. Now, unfortunately, for those of us who would like to see justice done, Leopold is in a very strong position here. This has been horrendous publicity for Belgium. Dominic, I mean, important just to say that there are a lot of Belgians who have also been participating in this campaign, a lot of journals, a lot of magazines, a lot of newspapers.
所以并不是说没有比利时人对正在发生的事情感到震惊，就像其他人一样。当然，特别是在他们的比利时政客中，绝对有人对此感到万分懊恼，并对他们国家的名称与此联系在一起感到惊恐。绝对如此。我的意思是，这并不是因为这全是利奥波德国王的项目。确实有比利时人参与其中。我们完全说得对。
So it's not like there are Belgians who are not appalled by what's been going on, just like everyone else. Of course, especially in their Belgian politicians who are absolutely mortified by this and horrified that the name of their country has been associated with this. Absolutely. I mean, this isn't because this has been King Leopold's project. There have been Belgians involved. We absolutely right.
有比利时人吹哨，也有比利时人真的、真的很震惊并为此开展运动。但对比利时政府来说，我的意思是，你能为一个小国找到更糟糕的公关吗？显然不可能。英国和美国正在给他们施加巨大的压力。你们绝对不能让利奥波德把这个卖给法国或德国。我们不希望法国人或德国人控制刚果及其所有的橡胶以及这一切。所以比利时人在这种英美压力下决定他们必须自己把它从他手里买下来，他们确实这么做了。由于他那些漏洞百出的账目，谈判花了很长时间，超过了一年，但在1908年3月，他们最终同意支付他5000万法郎，这相当于当今
There have been Belgians who have blown the whistle and there have been Belgians who have been really, really shocked and campaigned against it. But for the Belgian government, I mean, could you get worse publicity for a small country? Obviously you couldn't. And the British and the Americans are putting them under intense pressure. You cannot let Leopold sell this to France or Germany. We don't want the French or the Germans to get hold of the Congo and all of its rubber and all of this. So the Belgians decide under this Anglo-American pressure they're going to have to buy it off him themselves and they do. Because of his dodgy accounts the negotiations take ages more than a year but in March 1908 they finally agree they will pay him 50 million francs which is the
数十亿英镑或美元。谢天谢地，利奥波德没有太长时间去花他的这笔横财，因为他在1909年12月去世了，死因可能是癌症。当然，既然是利奥波德，他的死也是一桩弥天大丑闻，因为事实证明，就在他死前不久，他秘密娶了他的情妇卡洛琳，并且把他的大部分财富留给了她，而不是他的女儿们。因为我们之前说过，这是他一生的伟大抱负——剥夺他女儿们的继承权。还要补充一点，在利奥波德死后七个月，如今变得极其富有的卡洛琳嫁给了迪里厄。那个皮条客。我想霍克斯特说过，迪里厄
equivalent of billions of pounds or dollars today. Thankfully, Leopold doesn't have very long to spend his winnings because he died in December 1909, probably of cancer. Of course, Leopold being Leopold, his death is a massive scandal because it turned out that he'd secretly married his mistress, Caroline, just before his death and he'd left her most of his fortune, not his daughters. Because we talked about that this was the great ambition of his life is to disinherit his daughters. And also just to add that seven months after Leopold's death, Karoline, who is now enormously rich, marries Dürer. The pimp. And I think Hochstrand says that Dürer
很可能是拉皮条历史上最成功的皮条客。我的天呐。他可谓收获了最大的经济回报。因为基本上，我的意思是，他赚了数百万、数百万、数百万。这是一桩巨大的丑闻，一场巨大的法律战，利奥波德的女儿们、卡洛琳和比利时政府为了争夺他的遗产控制权而展开了三方诉讼。
may well be the most successful pimp in the history of pimping. My word. He kind of reaps in the largest financial reward. Because basically, I mean, he's made millions and millions and millions. There's a massive scandal, a huge legal battle, three-way legal battle between Leopold's daughters, Gareline and the Belgian government for control of his estate.
我简直不敢相信罗伯特·哈里斯居然还没写过一本关于这个的小说。但问题是，这件事最终被人遗忘了，因为在他死后仅仅五年，勇敢的小比利时就成了英国在第一次世界大战中的开战理由（Casus Belli）。现在它有了一位新国王，他的侄子阿尔伯特。他成了比利时抵抗运动的伟大象征，不是吗？所以每个人都像是在说，让我们，让我们忘掉利奥波德曾经存在过吧。所以，但是可以说比利时王室得到了某种程度的“一战洗白”，我想他们确实得到了，是的，他们确实得到了“一战洗白”。
I can't believe Robert Harris hasn't written a novel about this. But the thing is, it ends up being forgotten because just five years after his death, plucky little Belgium becomes the Carthus Belli for Britain in the First World War. And it has a new king now, his nephew Albert. And he becomes the great symbol of Belgian resistance, doesn't he? So everybody is like, let's, let's forget Leopold ever existed. So, but say the kind of the Belgian royal family get what kind of great war washed, I suppose they do get, yes, they do get great war washed.
完全如此。所以让我们非常简短地讲讲这个故事中其他角色的结局。斯坦利当时其实并没有受到刚果丑闻太大的玷污。他成了一名国会议员，一名自由工会派国会议员。他在1904年去世。所以大约在狂热达到顶峰的时候，但它从未真正将他吞没。当然，现在，你知道的，现代历史学家和传记作家在书写斯坦利时，显然刚果在他的故事中占据了非常大的比重。
Exactly. So let's just say very quickly about what happened to the other characters in this story. Stanley at the time actually came out of this pretty untainted by the Congo scandal. He'd become an MP, a liberal unionist MP. He died in 1904. So round about the time the Fiori is reaching its peak, but it never really seemed to sort of engulf him. Although of course now, you know, modern historians and biographers when they write about Stanley, I mean, obviously the Congo plays a very large part in his story.
当时曾有过一场激烈的辩论，不是吗？关于是否要将他的雕像从他在威尔士的出生地移除。没错。我想他们保留了那座雕像。我想它现在还在那儿。凯斯门特——我们下周会在你和约翰·班维尔的节目中听到更多关于他的消息——最终成为了另一场伟大的人道主义运动的捍卫者。所以秘鲁亚马逊地区的橡胶工人。他是另一场伟大的人道主义运动的伟大捍卫者。所以秘鲁亚马逊的橡胶工人。他是他们的伟大捍卫者。他在1911年被册封为爵士，但随后他被另一个事业所吸引，那就是爱尔兰的自由。非凡的故事。最后他带着一船武器坐上一艘U型潜艇，试图偷运武器入境。
There was a big debate, wasn't there, whether to remove a statue of him from his birthplace in Wales. That's right. I think they kept the statue. I think it's still there. Casement, who we'll be hearing lots more about next week with you and John Banville, he ended up becoming the champion of another great humanitarian campaign. So rubber workers in the Peruvian Amazon. He's a great champion of another great humanitarian campaign. So rubber workers in the Peruvian
大约在复活节起义前三天。我的意思是，剧透一下，他因叛国罪被绞死。他大部分的刚果盟友都为他求情。莫雷尔为他求情。柯南·道尔为他求情。
Amazon. He's a great champion of them. He's knighted in 1911, but then he becomes absorbed by another cause, which is Irish freedom. Extraordinary story. And he ends up on a U-boat with a load of guns trying to smuggle weapons in. Kind of three days before the Easter Rising. I mean, spoiler alert, he's hanged for high treason. Most of his Congo allies plead for clemency. Morel pleads for clemency. Conan Doyle pleads for clemency.
但有趣的是，约瑟夫·康拉德没有，并且拒绝了。康拉德说，凯斯门特曾接受过英国的荣誉。他曾代表过英国。我们册封过他爵位，不是吗？然后他背叛了英国，你知道的，他这是咎由自取。所以康拉德是个相当保守的人物，这其实并不令人意外。莫雷尔继续就刚果问题开展运动，甚至在刚果被比利时接管之后也是如此。我们马上就会讲到这一点。但最终他变得激进起来，有点像凯斯门特。所以在第一次世界大战期间，
But interestingly, Joseph Conrad did not and refused. And Conrad said Casement had taken honors from Britain. He'd represented Britain. We got a knighthood, hadn't we? He had then betrayed Britain and, you know, he got what was coming to him. So Conrad's a pretty conservative figure, so that's not necessarily surprising. Morel carried on campaigning about the Congo, even after being taken over by the Belgians. We'll come to that in just a second. But he was radicalized eventually, a little bit like Casement. So in the First World War,
但有趣的是，约瑟夫·康拉德并没有这么做，而且拒绝了。康拉德说，凯斯门特曾接受过英国的荣誉。他曾代表过英国。我们获得了爵位，不是吗？他后来背叛了英国，你知道的，他罪有应得。所以康拉德是一个相当保守的人物，这其实也并不令人意外。莫雷尔继续为刚果开展竞选活动，甚至在比利时接管之后也是如此。我们马上就会谈到这一点。但最终他变得激进起来，有点像凯斯门特。因此，在第一次世界大战中，
Morel is probably the best known pacifist in Britain. And he ended up being sent to prison for sending pacifist pamphlets to Switzerland, which was in breach of the Defense of the Realm Act. He ends up joining the Labour Party. He stood for Labour in Dundee in 1922. He beat Winston Churchill at the House of Commons. It's amazing how all these figures kind of intersect. In their connect. I know there's a great book to be written about, you know, imagine a book with
莫雷尔可能是英国最著名的和平主义者。他最终因为向瑞士发送和平主义小册子而被送进监狱，这违反了《保卫英国法案》。他最后加入了工党。1922年，他在邓迪代表工党参选。他在下议院击败了温斯顿·丘吉尔。这些人物竟然能以各种方式产生交集，真是令人惊叹。在他们的联系中。我知道有一本好书可以写，你知道的，想象一下这样一本书
your characters like Conrad, Casement, Morrell, Churchill, all of these, Mark Twain. Anyway, he died tragically of a heart attack two years after being elected to parliament when he was just 51. So that was the end of him. But his legacy, of course, is a tradition of human rights activism that never really goes away. And obviously we're still very familiar with to this day. But before we close, we should just a word about the Congo. Because the real question, of course, is how does it change? What changes after Leopold is gone? It's definitely true that when the Belgians take it over, there are fewer reports of atrocities.
你的角色像康拉德、卡斯门、莫雷尔、丘吉尔，所有这些，还有马克·吐温。不管怎样，他在入选议会两年后因心脏病悲惨地逝世，当时他年仅51岁。这就是他的结局。但他的遗产，当然，是一种永不消逝的人权活动传统。显然，直到今天我们依然对此非常熟悉。但在我们结束之前，我们应该简单谈谈刚果。因为真正的问题当然是，它是如何改变的？利奥波德离开后发生了什么变化？当比利时人接管时，暴行报道确实减少了。
We don't have the same reports of burned villages, people being taken hostage. It doesn't seem to have been the severing of hands, all of that stuff. However, a lot of the caste in the Congo are the same people, the same officials, the same station chiefs. The force public continues with the same name. The rubber trade continues and there is still forced labour. Even after the First World War, the Belgian Congo is notoriously brutal. They're still using the chicots, they're still using forced labour. The focus has moved now to mining, copper, tin and gold, but the conditions in those
我们没有看到同样的烧毁村庄、人们被劫为人质的报道。似乎没有砍断手之类的事情。然而，刚果的许多阶层还是那些人，同样的官员，同样的站长。公共武力部队保留了原名。橡胶贸易仍在继续，强迫劳动依然存在。甚至在第一次世界大战后，比利时刚果也以残酷闻名。他们仍然在使用牛皮鞭，仍然在使用强迫劳动。现在的重点已经转移到采矿、铜、锡和金，但这些矿场的条件
mines are pretty horrific and thousands of people die. And this Tintin in Congo, Hergé, one of the, I think his second Tintin book, and he goes there and it turns out all to be the fault of Al Capone. Yeah, and Tintin in the Congo, you can't get it, you have to order it especially. You can't get it now. It's been withdrawn from sort of general sale in children's bookshops. It's seen only as a kind of historical curiosity because the portrait of Belgian colonialism and of the people in the Congo is seen as inappropriate for 21st century children, which I can completely understand, I have to say. Even in the Second World War,
矿井里的环境相当可怕，数千人死亡。这部《丁丁历险记：刚果》，埃尔热的作品，我认为是他的第二本丁丁书，他去了那里，结果发现这一切都是阿尔·卡蓬的错。是的，还有《丁丁历险记：刚果》，你买不到，你必须特别订购。你现在买不到了。它已在儿童书店的普通销售中下架。它仅被视为一种历史奇观，因为对比利时殖民主义和刚果人民的描绘被认为不适合21世纪的儿童，我必须说，我完全理解这一点。甚至在第二次世界大战期间，
when obviously Belgium is one of the allies, there's still forced labor and the colonial government demands 120 days per person of forced labor from its African population to meet the allies' demands for rubber, for their trucks, for their jeeps, for their tires of their airplanes and so on. So, you know, there is that dark side to the allied war effort. Now some scholars have made a case, tried to make a case for the Belgian Congo and have said, you know, great public health campaigns, trying to eliminate sleeping sickness and yellow fever and things like that. And there's perhaps a degree of truth in that. But one thing that people always say about their colonists is, you know, look at the
当比利时显然是盟友之一时，仍然存在强迫劳动，殖民地政府要求其非洲人口每人提供120天的强迫劳动，以满足盟军对橡胶的需求，用于他们的卡车、吉普车、飞机轮胎等等。所以，你知道，盟军的战争努力也有黑暗的一面。现在，一些学者为比利时刚果进行了辩护，试图为其辩护，并表示，你知道，伟大的公共卫生运动，试图消除昏睡病和黄热病之类的事情。这其中或许有一定程度的真理。但人们对他们的殖民者常说的一句话是，你知道，看看
results, judge us on the legacy. And the truth of the matter is if you look at what became of the Belgian Congo after 1960, after independence, I think it will be very, very hard to say that's a record to be proud of. And the role played by Belgium in upholding it as a territory supplying Western needs is taken up by the United States, doesn't it? Yes. CIA sponsored assassinations backing for Mobutu, who's, I mean, the kind of the parody of a kleptocrat. And I think we said this right at the beginning, that in a way Mabutu is the real heir of Leopold the second.
结果，根据历史遗产来评判我们。事实的真相是，如果你看看1960年独立后比利时刚果的下场，我认为很难说这是一份值得骄傲的记录。而比利时在将其维持为供应西方需求的领土方面所扮演的角色，被美国取代了，不是吗？是的。中情局资助的暗杀行动支持蒙博托，我的意思是，这简直是独裁者的讽刺画。我想我们在最开始就说过，某种程度上，蒙博托是第二利奥波德真正的继承人。
He is indeed. So this obviously still loads to talk about. And actually in Thursday's episode we'll be going back to the book that we began with, which is Joseph Conrad's Heart of Darkness, a great subject for a history podcast because it's one of the most influential works of fiction ever written. Conrad himself is a fantastic character. Extraordinary man. And the impact of that book is really, really worth talking about. So that's what we're doing on Thursday.
确实如此。所以这显然还有很多要谈的。实际上，在周四的节目中，我们将回到我们最初讨论的那本书，即约瑟夫·康拉德的《黑暗的心》，这是历史播客的一个绝佳题材，因为它是历史上最具影响力的虚构作品之一。康拉德本人是一个了不起的人物。非凡的人。那本书的影响力确实非常值得讨论。这就是我们在周四要做的。
But for our Restless History Club members, a day earlier on Wednesday, we'll be discussing the deeper questions from this series. So we'll be asking about the death toll, how many people died in the Congo Free State, and is it fair to call it, as some people do, a genocide? Is it fair to see it as representative of European colonialism generally? So in other words, does this tell us something very dark about European imperialism? And should we perhaps revise the sort of canonical version and, you know, what are the controversies that surrounds Adam Hochstrah's book, the book on which we've based so much of the series. So that's for Rest His History Club members.
但对于我们的“重返历史俱乐部”成员，提前一天的周三，我们将讨论本系列更深层次的问题。所以我们会问及死亡人数，刚果自由邦究竟死了多少人，称其为某些人所说的大屠杀是否公平？将其视为一般欧洲殖民主义的代表是否公平？换句话说，这是否向我们揭示了关于欧洲帝国主义的非常黑暗的一面？我们是否应该修正那种正统版本，你知道的，围绕亚当·霍赫希尔德的书有哪些争议，我们本系列很大程度上就是基于这本书。所以这是给“重返历史俱乐部”成员准备的。
And if you want to join, you can just head to therestishistory.com and then you'll hear it. Thank you very much, Dominic. Brilliant. Amazing, amazing sweep of a terrible story. As I say, we'll be back in our next episode with Heart of Darkness. And then next week, there'll be also a bonus on Roger Casement. So lots of Congo for now. Bye bye.
如果你想加入，只需访问 therestishistory.com，你就能收听到。非常感谢你，多米尼克。太精彩了。一个可怕故事的惊人、惊人的全景。正如我所说，我们将在下一集《黑暗的心》中回归。然后下周，还会有关于罗杰·卡斯门的特别节目。所以目前关于刚果的内容有很多。再见。
Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。